Guten Abend, wir sind Chaosradio 55 im Studio Andreas Oswald und Tim. Ein bisschen Tim kennen wir, Oswald kennen wir nicht so sehr. Du bist der Admin des größten IRC-Servers in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Ja genau, genau. Das ist nicht mehr der größte IRC-Server, das muss ich jetzt noch mal verbessern. Ist es nicht? Nein, das wechselt immer wieder. Naja, egal. Ja, ich hab in der Industrie einen IRC-Server, einen Chatserver, hier an der Freien Universität Berlin seit sehr, sehr vielen Jahren und bin deswegen heute Abend hier mit dabei, weil ich eben schon ziemlich lange dem Chatten verfallen bin.
Genau, das ist nämlich das worüber wir heute reden wollen. Wir wollen heute über Chatsysteme reden, wir wollen nicht nur über Chatsysteme reden, sondern auch mit artverwandten Systemen, wie zum Beispiel Multi User Dungeons. Dann wollen wir auch Musik im Hintergrund hören, während wir reden. Dann wollen wir vor allem unsere Systeme noch an Start bringen. Wir müssen hier nur mit einigen Windows Installationen kämpfen und irgendwie Webcams ihre IP-Adressen abluxen. Und wenn wir das alles geschafft haben, kommen wir wieder.
Outro Chaosradio 55.
Das klingt ja immer noch so wie in den Heiligen Heilen.
Ja, das sind die Heiligen Heilen. Sprich mal was, ich versuch das hier in Ordnung zu beruhen.
Echo raus, ich soll was erzählen?
Ja, hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wie vorhin schon erwähnt, haben wir heute als Thema uns die Chats herausgegriffen und auch die MUDs. Chats ist denke ich ein Begriff, der den meisten Leuten geläufig ist. Bei MUDs ist das vielleicht nicht unbedingt so, aber die Systeme haben auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge gemeinsam. Auf jeden Fall was so bestimmte kulturelle Aspekte betrifft und auch was ein paar technische Aspekte betrifft. Ja, chatten. Hast du schon mal gechattet?
Ja, doch, durchaus. Ich glaube, das hat jeder, als er seinen ersten richtigen Rechner mit einem richtigen Modem hatte, oder?
Ja, also ich hab das auch gemacht. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob das bei dir auch so war.
Ja, das war ganz grauenhaft irgendwie. Also da gab es im Andernet noch ganz, ganz wenig User. Irgendwie so, pfff. Also ich weiß nicht, also wir haben irgendwie mal angestoßen, als glaube ich im F-Net, also im IRG-Net in Deutschland das erste Mal die Zahl der User an die 10.000 ranreicht oder so. Das muss so 95 gewesen sein gewesen.
Richtig, ja.
Ja, da haben wir mal gefeiert. Also das fanden wir irgendwie ganz witzig. Und dann gab es die berühmten Netzblitzen und dann fanden wir das Ganze gar nicht mehr so witzig irgendwie.
Aha, also du bist ein richtiger Hardcore-IRGler.
Äh, war ich mal, ja. Also ich hab das so ein Jahr durchgehalten und hab dann auch teilweise, damals hab ich noch auf dem Land gewohnt und da hat man dann irgendwie keinen lokalen Provider gehabt und hab dann so Telefonrechnungen so um die 1000 Mark.
Also du hast dann immer auf dem Handy deine Mutter gemacht.
Genau, also es war sehr unangenehm.
Na dann bist du ja ein richtiger Experte.
Nein.
Warum nicht?
Ne, dazu hab ich ja euch. Also ich kann das ja nur bedienen. Also ich bin ja ein Windows-User eigentlich und da klickt man ja nur drauf. Und wundert sich dann, dass irgendwann mal diese Sache mit Port 139, das hab ich auch im.
Also du hast sozusagen Chat mit Clickybunti gemacht. Hardcore, mit Kommandos, du wüsstest jetzt nicht, wie die Kommandos heißen, die man eintippen muss, wenn man keinen Clickybunti hat.
Nicht wirklich, also für welche Kommandos meinst du?
Na, so was wie DCC zum Beispiel.
Ja, doch, das kennen wir auch.
Das heißt, du hast auch Raubkopien über das Internet verbreitet. Ich hab sie gekriegt. Super. Ja, mit Chats lässt es sich so einiges anfangen.
Ja, gemaddet hab ich auch mal, allerdings nicht so heftig, wie bei Unitopia damals.
Ja, dann wäre ja dann alles gesagt.
Wie alt ist das Irg, so wie ich es kenne?
Frag wie alt ist das Irg. Was?
Frag wie alt ist das Irg.
Wie alt ist das Irg? Frag ich doch.
Ja, wenn du das fragen willst.
Was? Ja hab ich doch gefragt, wie alt ist denn das Irg? Erzähl mal.
Das Irg entsteht, oder ist entstanden 1988, ist ein Finisher, Student wieder mal, Jako Eukerinnen, der seine Mailbox, also manche, was vor dieser Zeit liegt, mit einem Chatsystem ausstatten wollte. Und hat dazu erst mal einen einfachen Chat geschrieben, hat festgestellt, das ist ganz nett, das ist ganz toll.
Wenn du das Mikro ein bisschen näher an deinen Mund nimmst, kann man dich besser verstehen auch.
Okay.
Genau.
Hat diesen Chat immer weiter verbessert, hat festgestellt, das ist für meine Mailbox eigentlich schon zu gut, zu viel. Und hat es dann ins Internet gestellt, hat angefangen, im Internet ein Netzwerk aufzubauen von Rechnern, die dieses System benutzen. Und das ist dann von Finnland nach Amerika gewandert und über Amerika ist es dann zu Europa gekommen und hat sich dann auf der gesamten Welt eigentlich verbreitet, sodass dieses Netzwerk als globales Chat-System zu verstehen ist.
Und was war vorher? Nur Mailboxen oder?
Also vorher, was ich weiß, ist, vorher war das Bitnet, könnte man nennen Internetvorgänger, bei dem es auch so ein Chat-System gab. Man kann sagen, dass dieses Chat-System, was es beim Bitnet gab, das war das Bitnet Relay Chat, dass dieses System Irk inspiriert hat.
Bitnet, man sollte man dazu erwähnen, ist eine Art Internet, also einer dieser Internetvorläufer globaler Netzwerke, das im Wesentlichen auf IBM hardware lief. Das war im Prinzip das Netz der IBM Mainframes auf diesem Planeten. Und da waren dann auch viele Universitäten und Forschungseinrichtungen natürlich auch angeschlossen, weil es hatte ja eigentlich jeder damals früher immer, IBM, so sehr viel anderes gab es nicht, bis es dann halt irgendwie digital kam. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie funktioniert Bitnet, was ist das eigentlich? War das irgendwie Dateitransfer oder hatten die da irgendwie online?
Soweit ich weiß, war Bitnet schon IP?
Nee, IP bestimmt nicht.
Also ich würde sagen, es war Artinkron und es war dateibasiert.
Also ich weiß doch, was man da tun kann.
Ja, ich glaube so ist das.
Viel Tokenring und andere IBM Erfindungen, wahrscheinlich sogar AppStick. AppStick, das ist irgendwie IBMs Variante von ASCII. Die anderen haben alle ASCII gemacht, so wie man das heute kennt. Also die Kodierung der Buchstaben in Zahlen. Und AppStick, also EBCDIC, war halt irgendwie das System, was sich IBM für seine Mainframes ausgedacht hat. Und das ist eine totale Megakatastrophe. Zum Beispiel sind die Buchstaben, also die Zuordnung von Buchstaben zu Zahlen ist nicht so, dass du die Zahlen hochzählst und du zählst durchs Alphabet. Das funktioniert irgendwie nur auf den ersten zehn Zeichen. Und dann gibt es einen Sprung von einigen Zahlen und dann kommen wieder zehn. Was daraus resultiert, dass sie sozusagen so ein Hex-Diagramm aufgebaut haben. Also 8 mal 8, also 256 Werte. Und dann haben sie sozusagen das Alphabet geometrisch als Cube in die Mitte reingebaut. Also IBM hat einfach einen Würfel genommen, so ein Borgwürfel irgendwie, und darauf irgendwie seine Informationssicht drauf abgesehen.
Sind die denn bescheuert?
Das ist das IBM.
Wir müssen nicht die anderen fragen. Aber die Geschichte des Chats ist ja eigentlich viel viel älter und sogar noch älter als die Geschichte der Netzwerke. Das fing nämlich mit den Timesharing-Systemen an. Also ganz, ganz früher, da war das auch mit den großen Computern so, wie das heutzutage noch mit den sogenannten persönlichen Computern, Personalcomputern ist, halt immer zu einer Zeit. Und da Computer damals sehr, sehr teuer waren und viele Leute da ran wollten, haben sie sich überlegt, es wäre ja schlau, wenn da mehrere Leute gleichzeitig dran arbeiten würden und haben mehrere Terminals angeschlossen. Und die CPU hat halt abwechselnd verschiedene Terminals bedient, das nannte sich dann Timesharing und war eine bahnbrechende Erfindung. Und da gab es dann mehrere Terminals und da konnten die Leute, weil es ja keine Zukunftsrechte gab damals, sich gegenseitig auf die Terminals einfach was draufschreiben, weil alles im Computer irgendwie zugreifbar war, also auch die Terminals der anderen. Und dann haben die sich da gegenseitig angefangen Nachrichten zuzuschreiben, so was wie es gibt jetzt Essen oder so.
Es gibt jetzt Essen? Hier ist ja gar keine Gabel dabei. Da gibt es ja auch eine Garde.
Kleine Essenspause.
Das ist Fingerfood.
Das sieht lecker aus.
Wo waren wir?
Wir waren da in den Chatten stehen, das war bei den Timesharing-Systemen. Das war ganz lustig. Da gab es dann auch relativ schnell ein paar Tools für, die das ein bisschen bequemer machten, als einfach nur das dem anderen auf die Konsole zu dampen. So mit richtig kleines, wo man reingehen konnte. Talk war glaube ich relativ früh dann bei Unix dabei, wo man Leute direkt ansprechen konnte.
Hallo, irgendwie jemand möchte mit dir sprechen.
Als es dann Netzwerke gab, wurden diese Tools natürlich auch alle netzwerkfähig gemacht. Man konnte dann Leute auf einem anderen Rechner, die da eingeloggt waren, ansprechen. Damals war ja noch alles textbasiert und es gab kein Klicken. Und deswegen hatte auch jeder eine Textkonsole, mit der man das machen konnte. Heutzutage würde man dann einen Instant-Messenger-Client laufen lassen. Das sind also alles keine neuen Erfindungen, die uns versucht werden zu verkaufen. Das ist alles schon 30 Jahre alt. Ja, und parallel dazu gab es natürlich auch die Mailboxen. Der erste Chat, in dem ich war, war mit dem Sysop der Mailbox. Das muss 1988 oder 1989 gewesen sein. Und da gab es dann auch einige spezialisierte Mailboxen, die halt ausschließlich zum Chat da waren, wo es dann sehr, sehr viele nicht besonders schnelle MUDs dran gab. Vielleicht hat auch der eine oder andere damals Van Gogh TV wahrgenommen. Das war so ein Versuch, multimedial, interaktiv und ähnlich. Basword lastig, nur dass es diese Baswords damals noch nicht gab. Das alles zu verbinden. Da gab es also dann eine Chat-Mailbox mit vier Leitungen. Und gleichzeitig wurde das über einen Fernsehschirm gebroadcasted. Man konnte da auch anrufen, miteinander reden. Und man hatte sehr schön diesen Hallo, Hallo, Hallo. Hallo, hörst du mich? Ja, ich höre dich.
Wo gab es das denn?
Das lief auf Dokumenta, das war ein Dokumenta-Projekt.
Das lief aber auch im Fernsehen.
Ja, das lief anlässlich der Dokumenta sozusagen. Wurde das überhaupt erschaffen? Ich kann nicht ganz sicher, ob ich die Wahrheit da nicht etwas verdrehe. Es hatte mit der Dokumenta zu tun. Also da lief es auf jeden Fall auch. Und dann hatte man das einfach auf so einem Fernsehkanal. War das nur in Kabelnetzen? Genau, es kam über ein paar Kabelnetzen.
Gibt es jetzt nachts auf TVB auch wieder?
Das heißt jetzt irgendwie Kulturserver, und da machen sie irgendwie ähnliche Sachen. Das ist im Prinzip genau aus dieser Suppe heraus entstanden. Aber Chat ist halt interessant, dass eben viele solche Systeme, wenn sie irgendwie lebendig werden wollen, oder meinen, irgendwie mit einer Community zu arbeiten, dass da eben auch ein Chat so rechtlich wegzudenken ist. Das war ja auch hier bei Fritz eine der ersten Netzaktivitäten, dass halt dieser Webchat eingerichtet wurde, bevor es irgendwie eine Webkamera gab. Was tut ihr eigentlich an? Ich weiß es nicht.
Guckt doch mal bitte.
Wir versuchen ja immer noch, irgendwie Internet zu bekommen in eurem komischen Internet. Können wir mal ein bisschen rein winken, Oswald, kannst du bitte auf dem Tinten hallen? Sie sind gerade gespeichert.
Wenn, dann, Fritz.
22.30 Fritz, Kurzinfo. Mit dem Wetter, nachts nachlassender Wind, gelegentlich Regen bei 12 bis 10 Grad. Morgen ist es wolkig mit kurzen Aufheiterungen bis 16 Grad. In der Ziemeldung mit Jörg Popendi.
Der erste schwere Stellen dieses Herbstes ist es. Ohne größere Schäden war Norddeutschland hinweggefegt und damit glimpflicher verlaufen als befürchtet. In Großbritannien, Frankreich und Belgien kamen mindestens acht Menschen ums Leben. Am schlimmsten betroffen waren Südengland und Wales. Ein italienischer Tanker mit hochgiftigen Chemikalien ist heute vor der bretonischen Küste in Seenot geraten. Die 14 Besatzungsmitglieder wurden mit einem Hubschrauber gerettet. Bei stürmischer See- und Orkanböen war eine Bergung des leckgeschlagenen Haferisten bislang nicht möglich. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat erneut Kompromissbereitschaft im Nahost-Konflikt gefordert. In der jadamischen Hauptstadt Amman sagte Schröder, Israelis und Palästinenser müssten die Vereinbarung von Shamil Sheikh umsetzen und die Gewalt beenden. Schröder wird morgen in Israel unter Mittwoch im palästinensischen Autonomiegebiet erwartet. Eine Expertenkommission soll die Flucht des Gewaltfabriker Schmökel untersuchen. Sie wurde vom Brandenburger Sozialministerium angesetzt und nimmt am Sonnenabend ihre Arbeit auf. Trotz hunderter Hinweise gibt es bislang keine heiße Spur von Schmökel. Verkehr an Neu-Berlin Richtung Leipzig. Zwischen drei Quotzam und Beelzeilstätten behindert ein brennendes Fahrzeug den Verkehr. Bitte Vorsicht bei der Annäherung.
Hier ist Jörn Dose mit einem super brandheißen Extremtipp. Jetzt mal die Lauterchen ganz weit aufgefahren. Und zwar ist es so, dass ich mich mit Studio Braun zusammen auf unserer ersten Deutschland-Tournee befinde.
Studio Braun, live in Berlin, Mittwoch, 8. November in der Kolumbiale.
Und ich mich extrem freuen würde, wenn da ganz, ganz, ganz viele Leute kämen.
Und alle selbst gebastelten Herren.
Es wird eine extrem super Show. Wir wollen in der Innenstadt was kaputt machen.
Okay, wer als Erster auflegt, ja?
Auf die Plätze fertig.
zum nächsten.
Wenn fünf Minuten lang kein Kabel kommt... Ich hab gelernt, wenn fünf Sekunden lang kein Signal kommt wie das eben war, dann geht hier eine rote Lampe an.
Senderausfall.
Klasse, ne?
Ja, wir reden ja nicht nur über Chats und MUDs, sondern wir machen das auch selbst, hab ich mir sagen lassen von dir eigentlich eben.
Erzähl mal.
Wir machen das... Also auf jeden Fall wollte ich mal so ein bisschen erwähnen, weil die Mails gehen heute irgendwie nicht so richtig toll raus. Erstmal, wer noch nach einem Streaming Server sucht, MP3 Streaming ist an. Die Links dazu findet ihr auf ChaosradioCCCDE auf der Seite für die Radiosendung 55. Einfach auf das erste News-Item draufklicken. Da findet ihr auch noch ein paar andere Links. Unter anderem ein Link auf ein Webinterface für ein MUD-System, also für ein solches Multi User Dungeon, so ein elektronisches Rollenspiel, auf das wir heute thematisch noch kommen wollen.
Also da ich momentan noch kein Internet in diesem Studio habe, bin ich auch noch nicht in dem MUD. Ich wollte aber schon mal darauf hinweisen, dass ich extra ein eigenes MUD aufgesetzt habe, damit man da auch mal ein bisschen rumbasteln kann. Also jeder, der sich da einen Account einträgt, kann auch gleich programmieren, kann sich da mal durchklicken, kann gucken, wie das so funktioniert hinter den Kulissen, wenn er die notwendige Zeit und Energie mitbringt. Es gibt einiges rauszufinden da.
Und dann gibt es auch noch die Möglichkeit, im gleichen Chat-Kanal zu landen, wie wir das hier sind. Und zwar müsst ihr auf den IRC-Server irc.ccc.de gehen. Und da dann halt im Kanal Lattensound Chaosradio. Ja, da könnt ihr ja mal auftauchen, da ist noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das mit den Pausen zwischen der Musik.
Ja, das ist technisch bedingt.
Ich bin ein bisschen schmerzhaft.
Ja, mit dem IRC ist das nämlich so eine Sache. Das ist nämlich ganz schön komplex. Hat sich so einiges entwickelt an Zofair. Was sagst du, das ist aus dieser, was war das, ein Finne?
Es war wieder mal ein Finne, ja.
Wieder mal ein Finne. Ja, die Jungs sind da immer sehr finnig gewesen. Sehr finnig. Ja, sicher. Naja, aber mittlerweile hat das doch eine gewaltige Eigendynamik entwickelt. Es gibt halt nicht nur einen Irgserver, sondern...
Es gibt mehrere Irgserver. Ich hab schon angedeutet, dass Irg das erste, oder eines der ersten Chatsysteme war, die weltweit waren. Und technisch bedingt aus muss es quasi in jedem Land, oder dass jeder Region einen Stellvertreter für dieses Netzwerk geben, so ein Irgserver. Und über diese Irgserver wird eben kommuniziert. Die Anzahl dieses Irgserver ist theoretisch nicht beschränkt, aber dadurch, dass die Software, die der Jako Eukerin da geschrieben hat, eigentlich für kleine Systeme gedacht waren, nicht für weltweite Systeme geeignet. Aus diesem Grund sind sehr, sehr große Irgnetzwerke sehr instabil und funktionieren nicht hundertprozentig. Oder funktionieren nicht wirklich gut, nicht brauchbar. Und aus diesem Grund, aus ihrer Notwendigkeit, dass ein Netzwerk klein sein muss, um zu funktionieren, gab es dann auch immer mehr Netzwerke. Es war eine technische Notwendigkeit, dass das passiert.
Also einerseits mehr Serverzusammenschlüsse sind das ja im Prinzip, diese Netze. Also als User nimmt man eigentlich mehr an seinem Server teil und der Server hat sozusagen eine eigene Party mit allen anderen Servern, wodurch die User dann auch mit drin sind.
Von den Partys gibt es jetzt mehrere.
Genau und die großen vier sind Irgnet.
Irgnet, FNet, FNet ist das zweite, dann Andernet und vielleicht noch Darlnet. Das sind so die vier großen Irgnetzwerke.
Die fahren aber auch alle unterschiedliche Software.
Die fuhren ursprünglich gleiche Software, aber dadurch, dass die Netzwerke sich getrennt haben, was teilweise auch politische Gründe hatte, also internpolitische Gründe, haben sich auch unterschiedliche Softwareversionen entwickelt. Weil auf dem einen ist die Überwachung durch die Betreibe des Netzwerkes größer als in dem anderen Netzwerk. Und deswegen muss sich die Software auch in diese Richtung entwickeln, in Möglichkeiten der Überwachung bieten oder der Einschränkung des Managements.
Also User Features sozusagen. Die Leute wollen Features und dann kommt es ganz drauf mal an, welches Netz das ausprägt und danach sucht man sich das. Gibt es eigentlich irgendeinen Meta-Kanal, der irgendwie über alle Netze irgendwie aufrechterhalten wird durch irgendeinen Hack? Weiß ich gar nicht.
Schön wär's, aber es ist leider technisch überhaupt nicht notwendig. Äh, möglich, weil die Server schon so unterschiedlich sind im Protokoll, dass sie miteinander sprechen.
Was wäre dann so ein 110-Protokoll? So, wenn es einfach mal ganz, wenn es irgendwas gibt, was man in der Welt unbedingt mitteilen muss. Wer schreibt das doch mal?
Das Protokoll ist ja sowieso ganz furchtbar. Man merkt ihm auch deutlich an, dass es aus Finnland stammt. Da werden gewisse Sonderzeichen zum Beispiel umencoded. Wenn man Channel sortiert, gibt es da ganz merkwürdige Ausnahmen von einer Sortiereinfolge, die mit eckigen Klammern zu tun hat, die halt in Finnland mit Sonderzeichen belegt waren. Und ähnliche Geschichten. Daher kommt das.
Das war sozusagen der finnische ASCII-Variante.
Genau. ASCII steht ja für American Standard Code for Information Interchange. Und die Amerikaner denken ja meistens nicht über ihren Tellerrand hinaus und schon gar nicht an Leute mit anderen Zeichen setzen. Deshalb war es halt damals üblich, dass jedes Land so seinen eigenen Hack hatte. Oder noch schlimmer, jeder Rechner in jedem Land hatte seinen eigenen Hack. Mittlerweile ist das ja mehr oder weniger abgeschafft, aber in Irk gibt es das Problem halt nach wie vor.
Wird vor allem viel gestritten so, nicht? Auf den Irknetz. Die Administratoren haben sich gegenseitig in den Haaren und die Operator haben sich gegenseitig in den Haaren.
Das sind eben alles nur Menschen.
Und warum haben sich die Administratoren gegenseitig in den Haaren? Also das mit den Operatoren kann ich ja verstehen. Das hat was mit Macht zu tun. Und jeder, der dieses dämliche Ad vor seinem Namen hat, flippt erstmal aus.
Ich würde sagen, es hat bei den Administratoren schon ähnliche Gründe. Nein, nein, nein. Nein, es gibt einfach unterschiedliche Art und Weisen, wie du so ein Netzwerk administrieren kannst und unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen, dass du sagen kannst, ok, ich möchte, dass meine Benutzer die Möglichkeit haben, hier alles zu machen, was sie wollen. Ich zensiere nichts. Ich beschränke nichts. Ich schränke nichts ein. Und dann gibt es andere, die sagen, ja, das ist zwar alles sehr, sehr gut, was du davor hast, aber dieses Medium sollte dazu da sein, dass Leute kommunizieren sollen. Und wenn es da Stirnfriede gibt, dann müssen wir was gegen die tun, damit die Kommunikation stattfinden kann. Und in dem Fall muss ich mich dann eben einmischen in das Vorgehen in diesem Netzwerk.
Das ist dann aber mehr so die deutsche Chatkultur, die sich da ausgeprägt hat?
Nee, gar nicht mal. Gar nicht mal. Nicht wirklich. Also die Deutschen sind in dem Fall sehr liberal sogar.
Und wer ist es nicht?
Ach ja, Gott. Ich würde sagen die Amerikaner.
Ach, ich dachte das ist das Land der Freien.
Also das ist, ich meine da dürfen Kinder rumlaufen, andere Kinder erschießen und die haben Probleme irgendwie ihre Irkserver.
Also ist das halt in den Irkschanneln auch, dass die Leute rumrennen und sich gegenseitig erschießen bzw. sich ihre Channel wegnehmen und ein sehr beliebtes Spiel. Und naja, die Latte der Maßnahmen, die man dagegen ergreift, die sind halt von verschiedenen Philosophien geprägt, die von Netz zu Netz unterschiedlich sind. Zum Beispiel gibt es halt unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber, ob man sogenannte Bots verwenden darf. Bots sind also Programme, die den Channel offen halten und auch den Operatorstatus jeweils nur an die richtigen Leute rausgeben oder wie weit die Identität der User geprüft werden muss und so weiter und so fort, ob man seinen Nicknamen wechseln kann, ob man überhaupt noch User von der Telekom reinlässt oder ob man das nicht tut, weil man ja nicht nachverfolgen kann, wo die User herkommen und so weiter und so fort.
Chaosradio 55, wir reden über Chats und MUDs. Über MUDs haben wir noch gar nicht geredet.
Machen wir aber noch.
Machen wir noch.
Aber jetzt ist auch schön so.
So ist auch schön, die Musik ist auch grad schön.
Thema Bots hatten wir gerade und nun ist es ja so, dass man heutzutage Bots im Wesentlichen nutzt, um Channels offen zu halten und früher waren ja Bots...
Vielleicht eine kurze Erläuterung, worum es sich handelt bei Bots.
Ja, Bots sind Programme, also nicht Leute, die in dem Kanal drin sind, sondern Programme, die so tun, als ob sie Leute wären, im Prinzip, die auch ganz normal wie alle anderen User auftauchen und die bestimmte Aktionen veranlassen können, die User sonst von Hand machen, wie zum Beispiel anderen Leuten Operator Status geben.
Oder einfach mitreden.
Auch das ja. Und ob das Wort Ficken mit einem Kick reagieren oder so was.
Und das war aber auch nicht immer so, sondern es gab ja bis 95 ein Bot-Verbot im Internet.
Ja, äh, vielleicht klassisch vorausschicken noch. Wenn der letzte User den Channel verlässt, ist der Channel weg. Genau, damit der letzte User nicht...
Und damit das nicht passiert, dass sich ein Fremder diesen Channel belegt, dazu wurden dann Bots eingesetzt. Oder werden Bots eingesetzt. Damit er nicht nur ein Operator wird.
Genau, also nicht ein Fremder.
Mach das bitte aus.
Also ein Kanal, also sozusagen eine Diskussionsebene auf dem Irkserver hat halt Operatoren, Leute, die eben andere Leute rausschmeißen dürfen und andere Features ein- und ausstellen können. Und per Default ist der Erste, der halt reingeht in den Kanal, der ihn eigentlich erst erzeugt, ist halt Operator und er bestimmt, wer halt außerdem noch Moderator wird. Und wenn halt alle Leute, die da irgendwie was zu sagen haben oder sagen haben sollten, sozusagen aussteigen, dann ist halt der Posten frei und der nächste kriegt das halt. So und diese Bots sind eben eine Methode, um unter anderem auch sicherzustellen, dass bestimmte Regeln eingehalten werden, also nach Hausmeisterfunktion übernehmen. Und was hatte, was war dann in Irknet das Problem mit den Bots?
Ich will es unbedingt sagen, weil es schon angesprochen wurde. Ursprünglich war der klassische Gedanke im Irk ist, dass Bots verboten sind, weil man sagt, okay, dieses Netzwerk ist zum Kommunizieren da. Bots sind nicht zum Kommunizieren da. Die machen irgendwas anderes. Die vertreten nicht miteinander, wie Menschen das tun. Und es gab natürlich auch Bots, die illegal eingesetzt wurden. Du kannst einem Bot, das von außen nicht ansehen, ob ein Bot ist, und deswegen ist er erstmal da. Und dann wurden Bots dummerweise eben nicht für einen guten Zweck eingesetzt, sondern für einen schlechten Zweck, nämlich solche Channels zum Beispiel zu stören, indem ich einen Bot auf so einen Channel setze und der einfach anfängt, wesentliches Zeug zu brabbeln. Das super schnell und schon ist auf diesem Channel keine Kommunikation mehr möglich. Und gegen so eine Art Angriff, die Null of Serves Attack von mir aus, kannst du eben als Mensch nichts tun. Und deswegen wurden dann Bots auf der anderen Seite eingesetzt, um solche Bots zu erkennen und dann rauszuschmeißen, eben super schnell. Und aus diesem Grund wurde dann in Deutschland diese Bot-Verbot-Regel aufgehoben, sodass die Leute quasi die Möglichkeit hatten, sich zu wehren gegen diese Angriffe. Wer bestimmt das?
Also, ich meine, wer ist da das Gremium? Wie laufen da die Entscheidungen?
Das läuft so ab, dass die Betreiber dieser Server, die Administratoren, dass die abstimmen in einer gewissen Region, zum Beispiel Deutschland, und für diese Region dann die Regeln definieren können. Die stüben untereinander ab, haben verschiedene Vorschläge und der Mehrheitsentscheid, die Regel wird dann eingesetzt, durch Gesetz aktiviert, wie auch immer.
Wie läuft da das Voting? Ist das E-Mail und man diskutiert so lange auf einer Mailingliste, bis man einen Konsens findet, oder gibt es da auch einen geregelten Modus?
Man macht einen Call for Vote, das wird vielleicht auch vorher noch diskutiert. Dann wird das, was diskutiert wurde, zur Abstimmung gestellt. Und dann kann jeder Server mit einer Stimme abstimmen, ob er das möchte oder nicht. Und da wird dann ab einer Zweidrittelmehrheit akzeptiert.
Wie viele gibt es insgesamt in Deutschland?
Es sind immer so neun oder zehn in der Größenordnung.
Das betrifft jetzt das IRG-Net. Aber das ist doch mehr als nur ein neuer Server.
Im IRG-Net sind es neun, weltweit sind es... Du kannst gleich mal nachkriegen, das war so 150, 200 Server.
Insgesamt IRG-Server in verschiedenen Netzen?
In dem IRG-Net.
Aber in Deutschland ist es manchmal eigene Regeln. Obwohl sie am gleichen Netz teilnehmen. Aber da machen sie im Prinzip Regeln auf etwas, was sie gar nicht beliebig kontrollieren können.
Das ist das Problem.
Ah, das ist das Internet-Problem. Genau. Wie wird das angegangen? Also ich meine, das Problem haben ja die Regierungen ja auch gerade, dass sie gerne irgendwas reglementieren würden und solche Sachen einführen, wie Steuern auf Bits oder so. Und irgendwie, dann sehen sie immer ein, dass sie ja eigentlich gar nicht die Entscheidungsgewalt haben und das auch nicht so richtig klar ist, wer eigentlich die Entscheidungsgewalt hat.
Also im IRG-Netzwerk sieht es so aus, dass ein Land seine Policy macht. Eventuell gibt es auch irgendeine Netze, wo es eine globale Policy gibt, wo es globale Regeln gibt. Das geht aber immer nur bis zu einer gewissen Größe. Wenn du da eben 150 Parteien hast, die unter einen hinzubringen, geht nicht. Wäre das bei zehn Parteien dann schon möglich ist. Und wenn es möglich ist, dass ein Land seine eigene Policy fahren kann, und macht es das meistens natürlich in vernünftigen Weise, wenn ein Land dabei jetzt total ausscheren würde, dann würden die restlichen Teilnehmer an diesem Netzwerk sagen, okay, die wollen wir nicht mehr, oder dann wird dieses Land abgeklemmt.
An diesem Netzwerk.
Dann könnte es sein eigenes Netzwerk aufmachen.
Also ein bisschen auch so, ähnlich auch so wie die Entscheidungsstrukturen bei den News Admins.
Ja, kann man durchaus vergleichen.
So dass es da nichts zum abklemmen gibt.
Ja doch, mein Gott.
Ja gut, ein einzelnes.
Da gibt es ja auch diese schöne, wie heißt das nochmal, Imminent Death Palliating.
Genau, die Using the Death Palliating. Hatten wir vor zwei Jahren, gab es doch mal diesen Vorschlag gegen AOL eine zu verhängen.
Ja, genau, das war halt genau so ein Ding. AOL, was haben die nochmal gleich getan oder nicht getan?
Du konntest mit den AOL Freistunden-CDs, ich glaube, da waren 50 Stunden drauf und die ersten 10 Stunden haben die, ohne dass deine Daten verifiziert wurden, das gesamte Internet aufgemacht. Also sämtliche Dienste. Konntest du benutzen, ohne dass du dich in irgendeiner Form autonifizieren musstest. Du hast diese CD in deinen Rechner geschoben, und konntest irgendwie eine fiktive Kontoverbindung eingeben, fiktiven Namen und Adresse eingeben. Und das Ding hat diese Daten einfach nicht verifiziert. Und du hast einfach 10 Stunden Zeit gehabt, das Usenet vollzuspannen, bis du schwarz wurdest.
Das ist aber doch nicht das Problem gewesen, bei dem Despanelist.
Ich meine, das wär das Hauptproblem bei dem UDP gewesen damals.
Nee, das war, glaub ich, mit Telekom, dass sie nicht alle Newsgroups übernehmen wollten. Ich krieg gerade was durcheinander, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, genau.
Bei der Telekom gibt es aber auch noch eine Geschichte mit dem IRG. Weil die Reselling machen für relativ viele kleine Provider, das heißt Provider, die keine eigene Infrastruktur haben, die sich das bei der Telekom einkaufen. Und es war eine Zeit lang nicht möglich, rauszufinden, zu welchem Provider die Leute jetzt gehören. Die kamen mit einer IP-Adresse tinterconnect.net und dahinter konnte halt eine von dutzenden Firmen stehen. Und wenn Leute sich daneben genommen haben, gab es halt keine sinnvolle Möglichkeit, auf den Administrator Druck auszuüben, nochmal seinem User zu sagen, dass er sich benehmen soll. Und da sind sie dann eine Zeit lang, vielleicht weißt du auch Näheres über den Vorgang? Ich hab das nur so verstanden.
Also wie du jetzt beschrieben hast, war es schon absolut zutreffend. Ich glaube die Zeit war vielleicht drei, vier Tage. Da wurde dann eine gesamte T-Connect von Irk ausgeschlossen, um so zu versuchen, Druck auf den Provider auszuüben, seine Benutzer besser in Griff zu kriegen.
Hat es genutzt?
Also sie sind jetzt glaube ich wieder drin, aber nur restriktiert. Das heißt, wenn man über T-IP Connect reinkommt, kann man kein Operator werden, kann man seinen Nick nicht wechseln und so weiter und so fort.
Man kann nicht die Dinge mehr machen, die man brauchen würde, um es brav zu betreiben.
Genau.
Ja, das ist ja doch eine gute Gelegenheit zu sagen 23 Uhr. Und zwar das Chaosradio Nr. 55 mit Tim, mit Oswald, einem Ergadmin und Andreas. Und ach ja, und ich heiß Holger. Die Musik ist wieder aus.
Hallo Holger.
Also das ist echt was da die Technik macht, die du da angeschleppt hast, das nicht. Das macht nichts, das hat damit nichts zu tun.
Wieso, was macht er denn gerade nicht? Der spielt schön in der Musik. Mit Pausen.
Ja eben, die Pausen sind schön. Chaosradio 55, was ich ja auch chatten fand irgendwie damals, das war so in den 80ern, da gab's, ich komm ja aus Köln, und da gab's in Aachen den Telefon-Treff, was irgendwie total absurd irgendwie kam.
Die erste echte öffentliche Telefonkonferenz, die Telekom frei geschaltet hat. Das war damals die Zeit, als diese ganzen Tele-Infodienste losgingen, was man heute so unter 090 kennt. Damals nannte man das noch Audiotex. Also Audiotex ist sozusagen die technische Bezeichnung für diese Szene, die halt irgendwie Computer-Anwendungen schreiben, um damit Telefone zu bedienen. Also Anrufbeantworter-Systeme, Auskunftssysteme. Und dann halt auch diese Sexlines, die ja dann so bekannt geworden sind. Auch wenn sie am Anfang immer davon geträumt haben, Hotlines und so weiter mitzumachen. Na gut, mittlerweile wird sowas auch getan über 190. Oder eben auch über andere Service-Nummern, wie 0800er-Nummern, also Free, Kram, Coil-Helder benutzen, solche Technik. Und Telekom war zwar so für Business-Anwendungen immer sehr aufgeschlossen und so hatte da so ein bisschen das Dollar im Auge. Man hat auch irgendwie rigide den Markt reguliert. Und dann war aber der Druck auch vor allem sehr groß, halt solche Sachen anzubieten. Das Problem war, dass das damals, dass es also voll in die Staatsprohalte hineinfiel, so zu vermitteln. Das heißt, es war diesen Audio-Text-Anbietern, die einfach die ganze Technik dafür hatten, nicht erlaubt, Konferenzen zu machen, wo die Leute einfach nur anrufen und miteinander reden. Was ja auch eine Business-Anwendung ist. Aber auch gerade für solche Telefon-Treffs oder so. So, da hat die Telekom eben in Aachen das erste Mal was gemacht. Und das fand auch einen interessanten Anklang. Und viele andere Anbieter haben sowas auch immer machen wollen, aber es ging halt immer nicht, weil irgendwie Staatsmonopol, dieses und jenes. Mittlerweile hat sich das ein bisschen gelockert. Ich hab es jetzt auch wenig aus dem Auge verloren, wie sich das dann weiterentwickelt hat. Vor allem geht das halt in diese ganze 190er-Szene rein.
Ja, was dann auch einfach ein bisschen teuer wird auf Dauer. Ja, aber der Bedarf... Das Telefon-Treff Aachen war eine normale Aachener Vorwahl.
Ja, aber es hat sich gezeigt, die Leute waren bereit, Unsummen Geld auszugeben, um irgendwie was zu machen. Man sieht ja heute auch im Internet, Gott sei Dank sind die Kosten halt so weit runtergegangen. Aber Leute, die ja in solchen 190er- und sonstigen Diensten teilgenommen haben, hatten auch horrende Telefonrechnungen. Haben sich also Leute ziemlich schnell ruiniert. Aber das kennt man ja auch in 80er Jahren, die ersten Leute, die halt Internet gemacht haben oder Usenet gemacht haben, die haben einfach Unsummen an Geld bezahlt, weil ihre Rechner einfach die ganze Nacht sich gegenseitig angerufen haben und Nachrichten ausgetauscht haben. Und es hat halt irgendwie sehr viel Geldeinsatz gebraucht, um überhaupt Kommunikation zu machen. Und sieht das halt schon ganz anders aus. Aber was interessant ist, an dem diesen Telefon-Treff achten und alles was später kam, es gab immer ein unglaubliches Bedürfnis in der Gesellschaft miteinander zu reden und irgendwie per Sprache zu kommunizieren. Der Klassiker, denke ich, ist CB-Funk. Klar. Was halt auch kostenlos war, man brauchte halt nur die Technik und wenn man sie hatte, durfte man dann eben irgendwie reden. Und das tun die Leute ja auch heute noch. CB-Funk irgendwie wird es immer geben. Und eine ähnliche Szene hat sich dann halt auch in diesem Telefonmarkt ausgeprägt und natürlich auch im Internet. Also da sehe ich einfach den Chat. Ist im Prinzip auch nichts anderes als textueller CB-Funk. Da hat man zwar nicht die Sprache, aber immerhin kann man sich gegenseitig lesen. Do you read me hell? Und bei Telefonen war es halt das Reden. Wobei ich denke, Telefonen ist eigentlich das, was also normal miteinander reden, das ist halt für viele Leute irgendwie immer auch das Tollste. Deswegen halt auch die ganzen 190er-Leitungen. Da wird dann auch ordentlich zur Kasse gebeten.
Und irgendwie dann darüber hinaus, also über diese ganz normalen Telefon-Treffs hinaus, gab es dann ja auch so Sachen, das hatten wir ja auch mal, als es noch die Sendung vor Bitten Fritz gab, da konnte man sich irgendwie per Telefon durch ein Haus navigieren und da gibt es irgendwie auch so ein ziemlich etabliertes altes Ding, die Villa heißt das.
Du meinst das Fritz Labyrinth?
Ja, das Fritz Labyrinth. Ich weiß noch nicht mehr, wie es hieß, weil das war vor meiner Zeit hier. Das kennst du besser, solche Dinge, ne?
Ja, ja, ich hab da auch mitgewirkt, in Teilen an diesem Projekt irgendwie und weil ich vorher eben was anderes gemacht habe, nämlich die Villa. Die Villa ist eigentlich ein ganz bemerkenswertes Projekt, ist halt irgendwie in der Frühzeit dieser Audio-Text-Ära, ist das Projekt gestartet worden und wurde halt irgendwie eine Software entwickelt, die im Prinzip einen Chat gemacht hat, aber eben ein Telefon-Chat, wo eben viele Leute anrufen konnten und dann eben so in so ein Cyber-Space eingestiegen sind. Das ist halt die Villa. Die Villa ist halt so im Prinzip Villa Kunterbunt irgendwie, alles ist verrückt, stehen zwar keine Pferde auf dem Schreibtisch, aber da gibt es halt so andere lustige Sachen. Es gibt da so ein Layout und man ruft halt an, kann da rummarschieren und dann eben auch sich miteinander unterhalten.
Kann ich da auch Sachen machen, also oder nur rumlaufen und chatten im Grunde? Oder kann ich da auch tatsächlich irgendwie in Aktion treten?
Du kannst auch in Aktion treten, das ist irgendwie recht intelligent. Du kannst irgendwie Dinge finden, aufnehmen, zum Beispiel kannst du ein Megafon finden. So bist du in irgendeinem Raum, schaust dich um und dann liegt ein Megafon dort und dann kannst du dieses Megafon nehmen und kannst es dann auch benutzen. Und das Benutzen ist halt dann abhängig davon, was du gefunden hast. Es gibt da unterschiedliche Funktionen. Dein Megafon bedeutet das, dass du eben eine Durchsage machen kannst, die alle anderen Leute, die auch gerade in der Villa sind, hören. Dann gibt es eine Durchsage, alle mal hier hören. Und wie dann das, was du gesagt hast, du nimmst also sozusagen ein kurzes Audio Snippet auf. Das wird an allen Leuten abgespielt. Also eine zeitverzögerte Verteilung von Nachrichten. Genauso wie das eben auch im Chat mit Text funktioniert.
Aber ich laufe da in erster Linie nur rum, worauf ich hinaus will, wir wollen ja auch über MUDs reden. Und MUD ist ja letztlich, so wie ich das verstanden habe, ein Chat, in dem ich tatsächlich agieren kann auch. Also Dinge bauen, Dinge kaputt machen und sonst irgendwas. Oder kennt Andreas sich aus?
Genau. MUDs kommen ja eigentlich aus einer völlig anderen Tradition als diesen Chat Geschichten. Und zwar kommt es aus den Text Adventures. Das erste hieß glaube ich direkt Adventure und hat den ganzen Genre einen Namen gegeben. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass man halt textbasiert und bekommt also eine kleine textuelle Beschreibung von dem Raum, in dem man sich befindet und sagt dann irgendwie geh mal nach Norden oder nimm mal alles auf, was auf dem Boden liegt oder tu auch Sachen damit. Und da gab es dann irgendwann Multi User Versionen davon. Wir sind also dann mehrere Leute durch ein solches textbasiertes Labyrinth gelaufen. Und es ging bei diesen Spielen dann mehr oder weniger darum, Monster zu verdreschen und Schätze einzusammeln und dann Krieger der Stufe 20 zu werden, mit der goldenen Rüstung so ungefähr. Wer Rollenspiele macht, kennt bestimmt die Thematik, aus der das kommt. Und dann hat sich aber interessanterweise daraus auch ein Kommunikationsmedium entwickelt. Also irgendwann haben die Leute festgestellt, dass es eigentlich auch sehr, sehr spannend ist, sich einfach so in diesem virtuellen Raum zu treffen, ohne dass es einen Bezug zu irgendeinem Spiel haben muss, sondern dass die Kommunikation an sich ja auch schon ein Spiel ist. Und da sind dann eine Familie dieser Multi User Dungeons entstanden, die sich rein dem kommunikativen Aspekt gewidmet haben. Also los ging das mit Role-Playing-MUDs. Später kam dann, also die Tiny-MUD-Familie war eigentlich die erste, die das aufgebracht hat, so Mitte der 80er. Davon gibt es halt relativ viele Varianten. Und so ein Chat in einem MUD funktioniert so ähnlich wie auch der Chat im Irk zum Beispiel, oder wie man das von einigen proprietären Diensten kennt, dass es Räume gibt, die dann tatsächlich, aber in dem Fall auch Räume sind, also die kann man sich angucken, und dann stehen da ein Möbel rum und liegen Gegenstände und Leute kommen rein und raus, die Türen gehen auf und zu. Die sind dann auch untereinander verbunden und man kann sich in dieser Welt bewegen.
Chaosradio 55, wir reden über Chatten und MUDen und würden ganz gerne auch mit euch darüber reden, denn das ist eine Sendung, in der man anrufen kann und zwar unter der Nummer hier.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Insbesondere würde uns glaube ich auch mal interessieren oder überhaupt mal mit Leuten zu sprechen, die wirklich exzessiv MUDen. Das macht keiner von uns, oder? Andreas, machst du das? Also richtig?
Nein.
Du bist da also auch nicht zuhause dann quasi.
Ich meine, das ist irgendwie...
Ich tu das mehr oder weniger, weil mich die Systeme, die dahinter stecken, interessieren, aber ich verbringe keine großen Zeitmengen da drin, weil ich da einfach auch nicht mehr die Zeit dafür habe. Wenn mich das fünf Jahre früher erheilt hätte, dann hätte ich da vielleicht mehr Zeit investieren können, als ich noch Student war und Zeit hatte. Früher. Früher.
Damals.
Ja, wer mattet denn von euch?
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Jetzt wird das gelten. Ich hab Zeiten in den Ferien, ich find's zwar wieder fern, wo ich wirklich extrem in den normalen Chats genommen habe, die auf Applets von Java basierten.
Und warum? Was reizt dich da dran so sehr?
Das Tool of Question mit den Leuten. Einfach mal so, sich die eigene Fantasie zu benutzen, abzumächtigen und sich Leute vorzustellen, vom reichlichen Auge zu formen.
Im Grunde ist das digitales Schönsaufen, was man da macht.
Quasi, aber es wird nicht interaktiver.
Ja, das ist allerdings richtig.
Was hast du gesagt? Chats oder hast du gesagt MUDs?
Nee, Chats, also richtige Chats.
Und wie viel Zeit verbringst du da so?
Nicht mehr, aber umgezogen sind. Und montant hier online ziehe ich am Arsch.
Wie hier online ist am Arsch?
Hab es noch nicht geschafft, den Anschluss freizuschalten.
Ach so, das wird kaputt. Das Internet ist kaputt.
Das wird gerade vielen Leuten.
Nee, also da haben wir, weil das ein Dummerfans, so schon 4-5 Stunden täglich.
Und hast du auch mal MUDs probiert?
Glaubt man sich nicht. Den Chat benutzte ich über ein Fanclub. Aber Matt und ich sagen, wir kennen uns nicht.
Ja, guckst dir mal an www.matt.de. Das ist glaube ich ein ganz guter Adresse.
Ich finde ja auch sehr faszinierend den Umgekehrtenaspekt, also nicht nur ungefähr die Leute sich vorzustellen, sondern auch eine eigene Vorstellung von sich raus zu projizieren. Da ist ja auch schon wieder die Überschneidung zu den Rollenspielen, zu den eigentlichen Rollenspielen, weil viele Leute ja auch im Chat eine Rolle spielen. Also sich als jemand anderes ausgeben, sich vielleicht älter, jünger, vom anderen Geschlecht oder was auch immer ausgeben. Und mal versuchen so eine Rolle zu leben und wie es einem so geht.
Warum man das macht, kann man hier beantworten.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Ja, ich bin schon seit langem hier gewesen und hab jetzt die Frage, warum können die Leute sich, also die Operator und die Akten sich nicht da auf einen Standard einigen?
Auf was für einen Standard meinst du? Einen technischen Standard oder einen Standard, welche Regeln gelten? Technischer Standard, weil es unterschiedliche Meinungen gibt und es gleich wie möglich auf dem Tisch war.
Also Bordeinsatz schön und gut. Ich war in irk.net, galaxy.net, ander.net. Überall, denke ich, läuft was Neues aus. Denken, das ist toll, jenes ist toll oder so. Aber warum gibt es da keine Regeln? Ja, es gibt ja Regeln. Man kriegt immer die Policy am Anfang. Aber dann kommt man auf den einen Server und dann ist die Policy so und dann kommt man auf den anderen Server und lässt die Policy so. Bei manchen Servern kann man sich nicht einlocken, weil man eben die Tilde vorne dran hat. Und bei anderen Servern geht das.
Warum soll denn alles gleich sein? Das Internet lebt davon, dass es alle möglichen Angebote gibt. Und es gibt Server auf den D&D-Regeln, Anlagswerke, in denen gelten die D&D-Regeln und andere Netzwerke, wo andere Begeln gelten. Und das ist doch eigentlich schön. Du kannst dich als Benutzer aussuchen, wo möchte ich sein, welche Policy, welche Benutzungsregeln gefallen mir. Und hast du eigentlich nur super Wahl.
Ja schon, aber allein schon im IRG-Net in Deutschland kann ich dann hingehen und wechseln den Server. Und schon bin ich als anonymer Benutzer im IRG-Net. Und wenn ich dann den Server wechsle, sage ich aber, nein, hier kommst du nicht rein, weil du anonym bist.
Kannst du dich, sorry, ist das ein Angebot an dich zu entscheiden, möchtest du anonym chatten oder möchtest du nicht anonym chatten?
Ja, Moment, Moment, aber es ist dasselbe Netz.
Es ist nicht nur das IRG-Net, es ist das Server.
Und ich kann mich ja, wenn ich irgendwo einen Bot in einem Channel habe, auch entscheiden, alle User, die von diesem Server kommen, nicht in meinen Channel zu lassen. Also da hat ja letzten Endes auch wieder haben die Channeloperator auch die Freiheit, das so zu gestalten in ihrem Channel, wie sie das möchten.
Also ich hab's so erlebt, ich war wirklich stundenlang, jahrelang im Internet und dann kam es dann so, dass Leute, die auf verschiedenen Channels in, zum Beispiel jetzt sagen wir mal Finnland waren, oder jetzt Deutschland waren, je nachdem auf welchem Channel oder auf welchem Server sie waren, hatten sie Rechte oder keine Rechte und dann kam es wirklich zu Kollisionen dazwischen. Irgendwann Deutschland oder dann sagt der eine so einfach, ja du darfst und der andere sagt, nein du darfst nicht.
Ja, das was du jetzt ansprichst, das sind nicht politische Probleme oder Probleme, dass sich Menschen irgendwie einigen müssen auf gewisse Regeln oder auch nicht, sondern das sind technische Probleme und das sind Probleme, die einfach auftreten, weil diese Netzwerke zu groß sind und wenn du ein großes Netzwerk hast, das sehr, sehr geografisch weit verteilt ist, dann kann irgendwo an einer Ecke dieses Netzwerks eben auch mal was zusammenbrechen und dann entstehen diese Situationen, wie du sie jetzt gerade beschrieben hast. Das ist traurig, das ist schade und dagegen hast du dich sehr schwer gemacht.
Moment, ich kenne es eben, dass ich in Internetcafé gehe und von dort anonym online gehe und auf der einen Seite sagt mir, nee, das passt nicht, dann gehe ich auf den anderen Server, der sagt, sie halten das.
Ja, da kannst du dich dann mal bedanken bei den Leuten, die alle anonym online gegangen sind, auf diesen Servern waren und da die Sau rausgelassen haben. Hätten die sich benommen, dann wäre es überhaupt kein Problem, dass alle anderen auch sich anonym einloggen.
Na ja, ich meine, was du jetzt bei deinen Kommentaren schlau bist, ist, es gibt da halt nicht nur eine Meinung. Es gibt da einfach ein sehr großes Netz.
Ja, genau, da hat sich eben die deutsche Irrgemeinde irgendwo einigen, dass es zumindest jetzt irgendwo eine Regel gibt, dass man sagt, natürlich dürfen anonyme Leute online gehen, aber sie dürfen nicht gewisse Sachen machen und nicht, aber nicht sagen, ich geh nicht rein.
Am letzten Ende ist es ja auch Internet und nicht unbedingt nur Deutschland. Und auch in Deutschland hat sich mittlerweile eingebürgert, dass es halt zu bestimmten Themen vielleicht auch mal unterschiedliche Meinungen gibt. Und wie der Ruf nach Regeln, den kannst du halt immer da irgendwie, wo dein eigener Einflussbereich ist, auch machen. Und wenn das irgendwie ein populäres Modell ist, dann wird sich das schon irgendwie rumsprechen. Und wenn die Leute das scheiße finden, machen sie halt was anderes. Und es ist ja eigentlich auch gut so, dass das so ist und dass es nicht hier irgendwie einen zentralen Irgminister gibt, der jetzt irgendwie sagt, bots sind gut oder bots sind böse oder irgendwie dieses jene anonyme oder nicht anonyme Feature muss rein oder muss raus. Das wollen wir ja gar nicht, weil er ja niemals in der Lage wäre, alle Meinungen und damit auch die Trends in irgendeiner Form abzubilden.
Nee, das meine ich jetzt gar nicht. Ich meine jetzt eigentlich, dass ich zum Beispiel auf Deutschland als anonymer Benutzer eigentlich nur auf ein oder zwei Server ins Internet komme und auch anderen Server nicht.
Was ist dein Problem? Warum willst du denn anonym sein?
Ich will nicht anonym sein, nur ich hab keine andere Wahl, wenn ich über einen Internetcafi online gehe.
Du hast keine andere Wahl?
Nö, wenn ich, also sagen wir mal, ich bin jetzt, also ich zurzeit bin ich jetzt in Hamburg, ich gehe hier in Internetcafi, gehe online als ganz normaler Benutzer, nur ich kann mich hier nicht irgendwie sagen, ich bin der und der.
Aber das liegt doch an deinem Zugang, das liegt nicht an dem Medium, das ist IRG, sondern das liegt an deinem Zugang, weil du dich mit deinem Zugang nicht autentifizieren kannst, weil Internetcafi im Anonym ist.
Ja, genau, das ist eben das Problem, ich bin jetzt anonym im Internetcafi, ich verstehe ja, dass dadurch meine Rechte irgendwo eingeschränkt werden, im Internet, und dass ich nur Rippe nachschmacken kann.
Sie werden doch gar nicht eingeschränkt, sie werden doch nur auf ein paar Servern eingeschränkt. Du hast gerade gesagt, du kommst über zwei Server rein, das werden deine Rechte doch nicht eingeschränkt.
Ja, aber wie kommt es dann, dass ich auf zwei Servern reinkomme und auf den ganzen Server nicht?
Na ja, weil auf den beiden Servern von anonymen Usern doch nicht so viel Mist gebaut wurde, würde ich einfach nur behaupten, oder?
In diesem Fall ist es eher so, dass diese zwei Servers erlauben, um diesen Leuten tatsächlich die Möglichkeit zu geben, reinzugehen. Und dann hab ich nur zwei Server, wo ich drauf auch passen muss.
Das gibt es auch in anderen Systemen. Zum Beispiel gibt es auch viele News Server in Deutschland, die verlangen halt eine Authentifizierung. Entweder implizit dadurch, dass es über deinen Internetzugang, wie zum Beispiel Snarf oder so reingeht, dann wissen die Leute, das ist ein Kunde von uns, den kennen wir. Oder du wendest dich halt an einen anderen News Server, der offen ist. Weil die meisten News Server lehnen dann sozusagen Leute, die ihm nicht bekannt sind, weil sie nicht ISP-Kunde sind oder weil sie keinen Kennwort haben. Und die erlauben dir dann halt auch die anonyme Teilnahme. Und manche machen eben auch, sind halt offen, aber du musst dich halt irgendwie anmelden. Ich meine, das ist ja auch nicht wirklich eine schlechte Idee, dass man irgendwie für das, was man so im Netz von sich gibt, gerade im Chat irgendwie vielleicht auch mit seiner Identität gerade steht.
Aber warum gehen die ja nicht hin und sagen, anonyme Benutzer haben einfach so und so Rechte und nicht anonyme Benutzer haben die Indie, also haben einfach...
Aber das Problem nicht die Internetcafés sind, sondern eben die Leute, die sich eben nicht zu benehmen wessen, wenn sie irgendwie anonymer reingehen.
Das ist halt der Punkt.
Danke für deinen Anruf. Und wir hoffen, wir haben deine Fragen einigermaßen beantwortet.
Obwohl wir uns ein bisschen von dem schönen Rollenspielthema weggehen.
Das ist richtig. Dann können wir nach Nachrichten nochmal einen zweiten Anlauf machen.
Dann, Fritz.
23.30 Uhr.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Nachts, da wird der Wind nachlassen. Gelegentlich gibt's Regen bei 12 bis 10 Grad. Morgen ist es den ganzen Tag wolkig, ab und zu heitert sich mal auf. Bei Temperaturen bis 16 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Jörg Popny.
Bei starkem Sturm ist am Abend vor der dänischen Nordseeküste der deutsche Frachter Farros in Seenot geraten. Die siebenköpfige Mannschaft funkte SOS, weil Wasser in den Maschinenraum eindrohend und das Schiff Schlagseite bekam. Die direkte Bergung der Besatzung durch Hubschrauber ist wegen des neun Meter hohen Wellenganges zunächst nicht möglich. Der vor der Bretonischen Küste gestreinete Chemikalientanker konnte inzwischen schlepp genommen werden. Eine Umweltkatastrophe scheint damit abgewendet zu sein. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat erneut Kompromissbereitschaft im Nord-Ost-Konflikt gefordert. In der jordanischen Hauptstadt Amman sagte Schröder, Israelis und Palästinenser müssten die Vereinbarung von Scharnmel Sheik umsetzen und die Gewalt beenden. Schröder wird morgen in Israel und Hittwoch im palästinensischen Autonomiegebiet erwartet. Eine Expertenkommission soll die Flucht des Gewaltverbrechers Schmökel untersuchen. Sie wurde vom Brandenburger Sozialministerium eingesetzt und nimmt am Sonnenabend ihre Arbeit auf. Trotz hunderter Hinweise gibt es bislang keine heiße Spur von Schmökel. Verkehr an Neuen Berlin Richtung Leipzig. Zwischen Dreieck Potsdam und Beelitz Heilstetten behindert ein brennendes Fahrzeug weiter in den Verkehr. Bitte Vorsicht bei der Annäherung.
Ich kenne einen, den du nicht kennst.
Und der heißt Benjamin von Stuttgart-Barre.
Wer ist das?
Benjamin von Stuttgart-Barre? Richtig.
Und?
Der liest wieder und wieder und wieder.
Gleich dreimal?
Ja, im Kolumbiaritz am 9.
10.
und 11.
November.
Ganz alleine? Nein, mit Gästen. Kenn ich die?
Die kennt jeder.
Fernsehen ist auch da.
Wo?
Im Kolumbiaritz am 9.
und 11.
November.
Sag mal, liest der nicht auch dieser Benjamin von Stuttgart-Barre?
Woher weißt du das eigentlich alles?
Hoppala.
Und hier ist das Chaosradio. Und weil wir auch immer an die anderen denken wollen, spielen wir jetzt noch ein schönes Lied für Marianne, stellvertretend für all die romantischen Seelen daraus. Weiß.
Das ist Shirley Wessey. Das Lied für Marianne. Und zwar für all die Mariannes oder wie muss ich das verstehen? Ja, für alle romantischen Seelen da draußen. Für alle romantischen Seelen. Hier ist Chaosradio 55. Wir wollten eigentlich über MUDs reden, sind ein bisschen ins Chatten abgedriftet, glaube ich, und klagen darüber wie die Server aussehen. Vielleicht ruft ja doch noch der ein oder andere MUDder hier nochmal an und erklärt uns, wie es denn dazu kommen kann, dass man sein Leben lang in noch nicht mal bunten, fremden Welten...
Hast du mal Rollenspiele gemacht?
Ja, aber irgendwie hab ich das absolut nicht begeistert. Wie hieß denn das?
Dungeons and Dragons vielleicht?
Ne, ne.
Schwarzer Auge?
Ja. Ja, das war...
Das ist nicht ernst genommen, das ist der richtige Rollenspieler.
Ach, nicht?
Das Microsoft Windows der Rollenspiele.
Ach echt? Ja, das ist genau das richtige für mich. Na ja, aber die gibt's ja auch...
Also schlecht war es nicht, aber es war wirklich irgendwie für Einsteiger so.
Aber es gibt natürlich eine super Hardcore-Rollenspielszene, die jetzt mit Computern gar nichts zu tun hat.
Ja, solche hab ich mal im Wald gesehen, die haben sich da wirklich mit Schwertern gekriegt. Das war echt hart gefangen.
So was gibt es übrigens auch in Berlin.
Ach echt?
Ja, da gibt es... Das hat natürlich jetzt... Ja, es hat auch ein bisschen was mit der Rollenspielszene zu tun. Zumindest hat es was mit dieser Kultur zu tun, die da auch dahinter steht. Bei der Sea-Base, diese Truppe in Berlin Mitte, die halt das Raumschiff freilegt, was unterhalb von Berlin Mitte vor ein paar Millionen Jahren abgestürzt ist. Die haben halt den Ausgrabungen im Systemcomputer auch kulturelle Informationen gefunden über die frühere Besatzung. Und ein Spiel an Bord war halt das Juggern. Das muss man sich so vorstellen, dass man so ein bisschen mit wilder Kleidung, mit überdimensionalen Ohrstäbchen aufeinander losgeht und irgendwie versucht einen Stein von der einen Seite des Fels auf die andere zu bekommen. Schädel, Entschuldigung. Schädel. Man nennt nicht immer einen Schädel, weil man nicht immer einen Schädel dabei hatte. Man nennt es halt auch mal ein Stein, aber eigentlich handelt es sich um einen Schädel.
Ja, Schädel ruft uns an.
03312 Potsdam 70 97 110 Hier blinkt irgendwie einer schon eine ganze Zeit lang.
Das ist halt auch dieser Aspekt des Rollenspiels. Man will halt in eine andere Gestalt schlüpfen. Man möchte irgendwie in einer anderen Zeit sein, sei es irgendwie die Vergangenheit oder die Zukunft, auf jeden Fall wo ganz andere Regeln gelten, als es so hier und jetzt in der Regel der Fall ist. Und vor allem möchte man diese Regeln sich selber bestimmen. Und wenn man sich selber seine Regeln bestimmen, sind Computersysteme natürlich ein interessantes Medium, wo man das relativ detailliert tun kann. Wir haben ja auch schon gesehen, dass da die Diskussionen immer sehr ins Detail gehen.
Ja, aber sind die Regeln so anders?
Anders als was?
Anders als das, was ich im Alltag habe.
Na ja, man kann sie in einen Programmcode stecken, der dann automatisch ausgeführt wird. Das heißt, man kann sich sozusagen die physikalischen Gesetze der Welt schaffen, in der man sich befindet. Das geht also schon bei den Irrkanälen los, wo man dann auf seinem Bot bestimmte Dinge einstellt, die erlaubt sind oder die nicht erlaubt sind. Und das geht dann über MUDs weiter, wo man tatsächlich Sachen ausgestaltet und dann zum Beispiel komplette geschlossene Wirtschaftsmodelle aufbaut. Also einige große MUDs haben tatsächlich eine begrenzte Geldmenge, die sich auch im Umlauf befindet. Man hat dann eine komplette Wirtschaftssimulation, die da hinten dran steckt. Und die Regeln dieser Wirtschaft, die kann man ja auch freidefinieren. Man kann also mal gucken, was passiert, wenn Zinsen ab sofort negativ sind, wenn Geld also immer weniger wert wird. Und auch ein Stein nach unten fällt, wenn man ihn loslässt, steckt halt auch in einem bestimmten Programmcode drin. Und all das kann man freigestalten. Und genau da liegt ja der Reiz drin, Regeln zu schaffen, die möglichst gut funktionieren, die dem gemeinschaftlichen Erlebnis, sei es ein Kommunikations- oder ein Spielerlebnis, möglichst förderlich ist.
Guck mal, vielleicht haben wir ja mal ein MUDder am Telefon. Hi, hier ist das Chaosradio.
Hier ist der Simon Stuttgart.
Simon.
Ich höre euch jetzt leider per Real Audio mit einer halben Stunde Verspätung oder so.
Na, dafür ist uns am Telefon ja live, oder?
Ich habe ein bisschen MUD gemacht. Also ziemlich exzessiv.
Du solltest vielleicht mit deinem Handy irgendwie eine etwas bessere Position suchen, weil du kommst nur abgehackt bei uns an.
Also 14 Stunden am Tag, das war halt während der Zeit nach meiner Schule und vor meinem Studium irgendwie so normal. Kauch so aus dem Bereich vorher Live-Rollenspiele gemacht, Rollenspiele, Pen, Paper auch. Und dann irgendwann mal MUD entdeckt, dann wieder vergessen, sind halt irgendwann richtig losgelegt.
Aber was ist der Reiz daran, wenn du richtige Rollenspiele machst? Dann ist das ja alles in Farbe, sogar in 3D. Und man kann was sehen und sich umgucken. Was ist gerade der Reiz daran, das rein textbasiert zu machen, was ein MUD ja nur ist?
Es regt eben die Fantasie doch mal ein bisschen mehr an. Das heißt, wenn ich zum Lab fahre, ist das natürlich alles wie Bundestag. Klar, logisch. Und der Erlebnisfaktor ist halt einfach mehr da. Aber einerseits kann man sich das nicht wirklich immer leisten, im Gegensatz zum MUD. Wenn man erstmal die Flat-Wave hat oder das Kabelmodem, dann hat man da ja keine Zeitbeschränkung. Und außerdem ist man selber auch irgendwie mehr gefordert. Also wenn man erstmal so einen bestimmten Status hat, kann man auch im MUD selber programmieren und die Welt sozusagen kreativ mitverändern und so.
Was für MUD-Systeme benutzt du?
Ich hab verschiedene MUDs gespielt. Am liebsten mag ich die TMUDs, weil sich inzwischen die Befehle bei mir wirklich eingebürgert haben. Da muss ich nicht noch extra nachdenken, wie es der Befehl in die MUD gerade heißt.
Hast du auch mit MUD gearbeitet?
Mit wem?
Mit MUD?
Mit dem MUD-System?
Ja, da sehe ich eigentlich keinen so großen Unterschied. Außer wenn man halt in den Bereich der Programmierung dann reinkommt. Aber so für den Spieler ist das ja eigentlich relativ austauschbar.
Und was für Welten hast du so vorgefunden und mitgestaltet?
Also ich geh mehr auf diese Mittelalter-Senten wie MUD. So Morgengrauen oder Unikopia oder so. Aber eigentlich prinzipiell diese Mixed-World-MUD. Das ist auch kein dritte. Science-Fiction mag ich nicht so sehr.
Mich würde mal interessieren, was für eine Persönlichkeitsverschiebung du bei dir einleitest, wenn du sozusagen am MUD teilnimmst. Ist das für dich jetzt nur so eine gelegentliche Sportart? Oder setzt du da ein bestimmtes Charakterleben über einen längeren Zeitraum fort?
Na ja, es gab halt diese Zeit, wo ich mehr mein MUD-Charakter war oder meine MUD-Charaktere als eben den Rest von mir. Das hat schon mit einer gewissen Persönlichkeitsverschiebung zu tun. Man ist halt sehr anders. In dem einen MUD ist man ein Herr Hexe, und in dem anderen MUD ist man irgendein Magier oder so. Das hat halt mit mir selber, also mit Simon, nicht so viel zu tun. Das ist halt einfach ein anderer Charakter. Und da liebe ich mich dann auch voll rein. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass ich hinterher in einer Relikate mich dann nicht mehr zurechtfinde oder so. Oder dass ich dann irgendwie mitten in der Nacht aufwache und überlege, wer ich jetzt grad bin. Also soweit geht das nicht.
Du legst also auch großen Wert auf den Rollenspielaspekt, ja?
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall richtig, denn sonst brauch ich ja nur in Irk zu gehen, wenn ich hier nicht Rollenspielen will. Da kann ich ja auch mit Leuten reden, aber ich denke bei MUDs ist halt das Rollenspielen das Richtige.
Also es gibt ja auch Leute, die in Irk-Kanälen eine gewisse Rolle spielen. Also das ist ja nicht immer so, dass man da als man selbst hingeht.
Das hat doch eine andere Qualität, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, wenn ich wirklich in einer simulierten Welt bin, wo halt die Atmosphäre stimmt, wo halt einfach... Also ich mag zum Beispiel den Irk nicht so gerne. Das ist einfach irgendwie so ein völlig leerer Raum. Während im MUD kann ich halt an bestimmte Orte gehen. Es gibt Orte, die gefallen mir. Es gibt Orte, die gefallen mir nicht so sehr. Das hängt auch nicht nur von den Leuten ab, sondern auch vom Raum selbst. Es wäre ganz schön, die Möglichkeit zu haben, einfach in einer völlig anderen Welt herumzuwandern.
Programmiere auch?
Im Gegenteil zu kommen, wo man im normalen Leben gar nicht hinkommen würde.
Das Mittelalter zum Beispiel.
Programmiere du auch mit an den Systemen? Also entwickelst du die Welten auch mit weiter?
Ja, also in Unitopia war ich zwischendurch auch mal Wizard. Aber Gott heißen die da. Das Problem allerdings ist dann halt einfach, dass die nicht mehr spielen dürfen. Das heißt, als Gott darf man sich von der Welt bewegen, aber man darf eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr mit den normalen Spielern kommunizieren. Und ihnen helfen sowieso nicht. Und da fällt dann eben auch der Rollenspielerspekt wieder weg. Und das macht zwar eine Weile Spaß, aber dann irgendwann hat man dazu, dass es mir keine Lust mehr gibt.
Sag mir mal einer einen Science-Fiction-MUD, weil da hätte ich ja Bock drauf. www.mud.de, mein Gott.
Ja, ja, geh mal drauf, da gibt es genug. Es gibt auch einen Seabase-MUD, das habe ich auch mal zusammen gebastelt, unter simu.seabase.org, Port 7777. Ja, c-mu.c-base.
Also c-moo.
Genau.
Ja, das sind halt so die beiden Extreme irgendwie. Also entweder ist es Science-Fiction oder ist es irgendwie die tiefste Vergangenheit. Hauptsache, es hat halt irgendwie so mit dem Hier und Jetzt mit nichts zu tun.
Gerade in dieser Textbasiertheit, um vielleicht auf die Frage von vorhin nochmal zurückzukommen, liegt ja auch eine gewisse Faszination. Na klar ist irgendwie, wenn ich durch einen Wald renne, das ganz toll, weil da hab ich einen echten Wald und so. Aber im textbasierten Medium kann man sich dann auch mal eben eine Wüste bauen mit einem 500 Meter hohen Elfenbeinturm drin oder ähnliche Dinge. Und ich denke, das ist auch ein wichtiger Aspekt bei Chat gegenüber. Sagen wir Videotelefonie. Warum hat sich Videotelefonie nicht durchgesetzt? Weil man nicht wirklich sein Gesicht in die Kamera halten möchte die ganze Zeit. Und man kann halt in Chat auch mal irgendwie eine zwei Meter große Frau oder ein schwarzer Gott oder was auch immer sein. Und das kann man halt in so einem videobasierten Medium nicht. Textbasiert ist auch in einem grafikbasierten Medium. Muss man halt für jedes Element eine Grafik malen. Und dafür sorgen, dass es miteinander funktioniert. Text ist so wunderbar einfach und kann wunderbar große Welten schaffen.
Das war's für heute. Also das mit dem technischen Pausentipp, das ist irgendwie... Ist das ein Bug oder gibt es da ein Workaround?
Das Genom's würde in diesem Moment auch nicht viel helfen, weil das Problem eine Festplatte ist, mit der der Computer nicht wirklich klarkommt und er kriegt irgendwie in unregelmäßigen Abständen so ganz ekelige Hardwareinterrupts irgendwie an dem Bus.
Scheiße, dein Computer hat Parkinson?
Könnte man vielleicht mit einem richtigen Kernel auch umgehen, aber in diesem Mac OS ging das halt derzeit noch nicht. Wie auch immer. Wir reden ja eigentlich über andere Sachen. Ja, über MUDs zum Beispiel reden wir über Götter. Da wurde ich gerade hellsürig. Eben gerade kam so diese Sache mit den Göttern. So man heißt, man ist da halt Wizard, man ist halt irgendwie Gott, man nimmt halt irgendwie eine Rolle und dann gibt es halt auch so Höhenabstufungen. Bei diesen anderen zum Beispiel hat sich das so eingebürgert, dass auch eine bestimmte Gruppe von Leuten Götter genannt wurden. Das waren das die Leute, die halt das System programmiert haben. Also die Programmierer waren sozusagen die Götter, weil sie sozusagen die Welt schaffen. Und das ist natürlich auch für Programmierer der Kick an der ganzen Sache. Also wenn man so eine Software schreibt, dann ist das nicht, das ist nicht Textverarbeitung. Auf einmal hatten wir ziemlich einschneidende Erlebnisse, zumal das System so gestaltet war, dass man während es lief die Bagger und den Code ändern konnte. Man musste also nicht das System jedes Mal die ganze Zeit runterfahren, sondern man konnte es irgendwie während es, also am zuckenden Fleisch, konnte man sozusagen Änderungen vernehmen. Das ging natürlich auch immer nur besser an einer bestimmten Grenze, aber im Prinzip hat es ganz gut funktioniert. Und dann kamen wir irgendwie in diese merkwürdige Situation, dass wenn das System lief und Leute drin waren, also dann tummelten sich dann so zwölf, fünfzehn Leute rum, liefen irgendwie durch diese Räume und haben irgendwie halt Dinge getan und vor allem eben das System, was noch entwickelt wurde, ausprobiert und permanent Fehler gefunden. Man war halt auch selber per Telefon und hatte so ein Headset auf, war halt auch mit im System und dann kamen halt die Leute und haben einen angesprochen. Ja, irgendwie, ich habe gerade das ausprobiert, das funktioniert nicht. Man hat ihm gesagt, ich bin gerade in deinem Programm und das funktioniert nicht. Ich bin ein Benutzer. Bitte finde dieses Problem. Dann wurde das Problem irgendwie lokalisiert, dann wurde es geändert und ohne, dass man sozusagen alles nochmal starten musste, konnte man dann sagen, ja, hallo du, der du in meinem Programm bist, probier das doch bitte nochmal aus. Das wäre geil. Dann verging halt nochmal eine halbe Minute und dann so, ja, jetzt geht es, prima, aber man könnte es ja auch noch so und so machen. Also eine unglaubliche...
Haben die Leute die auch gehuldigt und Opfer dargebracht?
Ach naja, sagen wir mal, bei solchen sozialen Systemen gibt es alle möglichen Überzeichnungen und so. Also ich meine, das mit diesen Göttern, das war schon eher ironisch, war aber auch schon eine gewisse Anerkennung mit drin, gar keine Frage. Aber wir hatten auch eine interessante Klientel, muss man dazu sagen. Das wurde mir auch erst irgendwie bewusst, weil wir haben uns gewundert, irgendwie diese Nummer ging halt irgendwie rum, aber die wurde nicht irgendwie beworben oder so, da wurden halt ein paar Leute gesagt, aber es dauerte irgendwie nur wenige Wochen und auf einmal war ein Massenansturm da. So dass also wirklich so 15, 20 Leute 24 Stunden in diesem System rum liefen und Stunden dann lang drin blieben.
Also über acht, zehn Stunden. Und da hast du dich dann dumm und dusselig verdient oder wie?
Nee, zu dem Zeitpunkt haben wir vor allem erstmal programmiert. Es war ja auch keine Dienstleistung, die schon irgendwie mit einer 190er-Nummer angeboten werden sollte. Sollte später getan werden und ist dann auch später getan worden, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt halt nicht. Wir haben uns vor allem gefragt, Herr wissen, in was für einer Szene spricht sich das rum? Die Leute waren alle sehr freundlich und da waren auch eine ganze Menge normalen Menschen. Also Menschen, wie man das hier zunächst einmal denkt. Und dann wurde uns klar, dass es noch eine andere Gruppe gab. Und das waren die Blinden. Das hat sich halt im Blindenheim Hamburg, hat diese Nummer wie ein Lauchfeuer rumgegangen und sie haben alle ihre CB-Funkgeräte in die Ecke geschmissen und in die Villa gekommen und haben sich da einfach getummelt. Und hatten irgendwie größten Spaß da A, sich besser auszukennen als alle anderen, B, in keiner Form behindert zu sein. Also es gab nichts, was sie dort schlechter tun konnten, aber es gab viele Dinge, die sie sogar besser tun konnten, weil sie einfach in ihrer ganz normalen Klangwelt irgendwie auf alles eben achten und Feinheiten rausfinden, die sind ziemlich bemerkenswert gewesen. Ja und irgendwann kamen sie mal vorbei und haben es dann beim Programmieren zugehört.
Seltsam oder? So, Tim und ich haben uns jetzt mal auf eine Seite bestellt und wir wollen jetzt mal in diese Villa reinhören. Vielleicht hältst du ein bisschen was auf der Seite.
Jaja, mach ich. Ich wusste aber, welches Mikrofon du es jetzt findest. Dieses hier? Das fiept hier alles.
Ich glaub Tim ist Kopfhörer an dem Mikrofon.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen.
Soll ich da rankommen oder was? Da haben wir sowieso Musik. So, haben wir das jetzt irgendwie on air? Ich hör das alles nur ganz leise. Ja, wir sind jetzt in der Witter irgendwie. Das heißt, ich hab da gerade angerufen und ich hab irgendwie meine sogenannte Schreibtischnummer eingegeben und ein Kennwort, Schreibtischnummer.
Das ist das, was da auf dem Zettel steht, die...
Nein, also hier auf dem Zettel steht was ganz anderes. Hier hab ich nämlich einen Lageplan dieser Villa. Das müsst ihr euch also vorstellen wie ein Haus mit drei Etagen und Räumen. Da kann man halt drin herummarschieren, indem man jetzt Tonwahlen eingibt. Jetzt bin ich halt gerade...
Wo bin ich denn eigentlich? Jetzt sind wir in der Küche.
Nach vorne geht's ins Gästezimmer.
Rechts ist die Diele und links steht der Kühlschrank.
Wir sind in der Küche.
Kann ich jetzt in den Kühlschrank gucken?
Könnte ich jetzt in den Kühlschrank gucken?
Ja, wir können auch in den Kühlschrank gucken.
Jetzt sind wir in der Küche.
Was ist das?
Jetzt kommt eine kleine Durchsage. Da hat wohl jemand das Megafon gefunden.
So, jetzt drückt man hier die 5 und dann eine andere Taste in die Richtung.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Warum nicht?
Hallo.
Wo bin ich denn jetzt?
Jetzt sind wir in der Küche.
Nach vorne geht's ins Gästezimmer.
Jetzt hat doch eben funktioniert.
Hi Tim, in der Küche bist du ein bisschen einsam. Geh doch mal in den Kühlschrank. Da geht's doch viel besser ab.
Also du siehst, ich bin zwar anonym.
Ich hab aber nicht ausreichend Anonyme, wenn ihr das gleich erkannt habt.
Jetzt bin ich im Kühlschrank. Es stehen gerade vier Leute neben dir.
Wir sind jetzt im Kühlschrank, es stehen vier Leute neben mir.
Und man kann sich halt mit denen...
Das sind jetzt alles Leute, oder?
Genau, das muss ich kurz erklären. Das ist jetzt sozusagen zeitversetzte Kommunikation, genauso wie das beim Chat auch ist. Das heißt, man nimmt erstmal was auf. Und dann, wenn es aufgenommen ist, wird das allen Leuten vorgespielt. Dadurch verteilt sich das erstmal sehr schön. Und man kann sich einfach nicht gegenseitig unterbrechen. Das ist nicht möglich. Jeder bringt seinen Kommentar, solange wie er irgendwie was dazu zu sagen hat. Egal, ob das jetzt irgendwie was interessantes ist oder was uninteressantes, wie es jetzt hier gerade vorher ist. Ich könnte halt jetzt auch was sagen.
Ist das jetzt eine richtige Konferenz?
Tim, du bist gerade in einer Live-Konferenz.
Ah, Scheiße, ihr habt eine Live-Konferenz im Kühlschrank eingeschaltet?
Ja, mittlerweile ist es eine Live-Konferenz.
Ach, siehst du mal, ich bin nicht mehr auf dem letzten Stand.
Ja, das glaube ich auch, Tim.
Ich versuche hier gerade irgendwie das Zeitpunktmodell einzuklinken und ich kriege es nicht mit. Ja, okay, also wir sind halt jetzt im Kühlschrank. Hier ist mir ein bisschen zu voll. Können wir uns nicht mal im Damenklo treffen?
Ja, können wir auch. Es ist auch eine Multi-Konferenz. Lass uns doch einfach in den Garten gehen. Geh einfach mal nach rechts raus und dann gehst du zweimal nach vorne irgendwie und treffen wir uns im Garten.
So, jetzt gehe ich rechts raus. Ah, das ist das Problem. In Konferenzen hat man so Rückkopplungsgeschichten, Laufzeitprobleme mit DTMF, wenn man die rausgefiltert und so, das ist halt auch ziemlich schwierig.
Jetzt in der Küche, nach vorne geht's ins Garten.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Spirit. Und allen sei gesagt, Schreibtisch Nummer 457874. Die Dame hat jetzt Geburtstag.
Alles Gute. Du siehst, also hier ist allerdings los.
Geh ich in die Diele, dann nach vorne, geht's in den Flur.
Und ich grüße Radio Fritz.
Und zwar ist das hier das Chaosradio 55 und wir versuchen gerade im Rahmen unseres Chats uns durch einen interaktiven Telefonschat zu navigieren namens Die Villa. Sag doch mal die Nummer, da kann man noch mitmachen oder nicht?
Ja genau, also normalerweise ist das halt auch so eine 990er Nummer, aber jetzt haben die irgendwie auch irgendwie so einen günstigen Zugang gemacht. Also die Nummer ist glaube ich 0406577 und 4x8. Dann kommt man da rein und entweder man hat halt so eine Nummer, so ein Schreibtischnummer, das heißt man kann auch Post empfangen, man kann die auch durchlesen.
Na Tim, ob das jetzt gerade irgendwie der Garten ist, weiß ich nicht. Du stehst jetzt gerade im Flur und das hier ist eine zeitversetzte Kommunikation. Sich dann drücken, sprechen und dann wieder die 4 drücken.
Ja der junge Mann kennt sich aus, jetzt mach ich das mal. Hallo irgendwie, jetzt hab ich's auch hinbekommen.
Ist alles gar nicht so einfach.
So, kurz aufgenommen, ich sag's so. Von daher ist es im Prinzip genauso wie ein Textchat.
Geht aber mal zweimal geradeaus glaube ich und dann kommst du in den Garten. Also ist viel angenehmer.
Bin ich auf der Sonnenterrasse? Wir sind draußen auf der Terrasse. Wenn man ein bisschen länger stehen bleibt, dann krieg ich noch auf jeden Fall so. Es stehen gerade ein Leute neben dir.
Ein Leute? Jaja, das wurde nie geändert, der Programmierer hat sich geweigert, er fand es lustig.
Ist auch gleich für ein Meter mit 5 und so.
Ja, das klappt doch jetzt endlich. Hier ist das amtierende viel angenehmer.
Es stehen gerade 3 Leute neben dir.
Oh Gott, da stehen 3 Leute neben mir. Jetzt kannst du deinen Gruß von Fritz irgendwie bringen.
Dann muss ich das hier nochmal zurücksetzen.
Ja, sitz bitte zurück, Achtung. Kannst du nicht mit dem Computer umgehen?
Das ist kein Computer, das ist teils. Kommt das jetzt? Achtung, ja jetzt mach...
Es gibt ja verschiedene Aspekte. Man kann das irgendwie ausprobieren. Aber wirklich gut kennen sich halt eigentlich nur die Leute. Vielleicht kann man ein anderes Modell... Was man hier halt auch findet. Wo sind wir denn jetzt?
Was?
Ich bin im Damenklo. Ich hab mich leider etwas vernavigiert. Du siehst, es ist halt irgendwie alles nicht so einfach. Wir müssen halt mit sehr abstrakten Kommandos arbeiten.
Dann...
Ich bin jetzt...
Ja, ich bin im Gästezimmer. So, da steht mein Schreibtisch.
Das ist sozusagen meine Mailbox.
Da kann ich jetzt halt mein Nachrichtenblätter...
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur Hallo sagen.
Was war denn die Vergabe von vorhin?
Drei.
Und zwei Stunden später ist man gleich drin.
Man kann sich gar nicht dagegen wehren, ich denke, wir können das an dieser Stelle auch abbrechen. Man kann sich so recht gar nicht dagegen wehren, so automatisch bei so einer Community einzusteigen. Dann kriegt man gleich soziale Bindungen und das Mögenwörtel.
Ja, und Frauen, die dich begrüßen, mit R.
R.
Ja, du fällst auch im Chat auch nur drauf rein.
Ich weiß schon, was Holger ab morgen macht.
Eine interessante Erdeckung hab ich da auch noch gemacht.
Ich bin eigentlich ein Mann.
Ich bin eigentlich eine Frau.
Ja, hier ist wirklich das Chaosradio 55.
Und hier gehts gerade super knuffig zur Sache. Was ich in dieser Zeit entdeckt habe war auch etwas, was wir Meta Kommunikation nannten. Gerade die Anbahnung, also sozusagen der Small Talk, ist eigentlich nur das Gerede über die Kommunikation selbst. So was wie, hallo, ich schick dir jetzt hier mal Post, schick mir doch auch mal Post. Und dann ist die Antwort, ich habe mich sehr über deine Post, jetzt antworte ich dir auch. Und dann kommt ein, ja, das war echt prima und so. Aber das reicht dann eigentlich auch. Das ist so eine Anbahnung, einfach so ein kurzes Wangengestreiche und danach bauen sich da irgendwie feste Bindungen auf. Also viele Leute kennen sich von, als ich da reingeschnuppert habe, habe ich irgendwie auch so Nicknames gehört, die kannte ich schon von vor sechs Jahren. Und auch so ein bisschen so ein Multi User Dungeon, wo man halt irgendwie mit interagieren kann, sich Sachen nehmen kann, benutzen kann. Man konnte sogar mal ein Telefon finden. Im Keller stand ein Telefon und das konnte man halt benutzen. Dann konnte man ein Telefon nochmal eingeben und dann telefonierte man sozusagen aus dem System, in das man sich hineinhilfe des Systems wieder heraus zu irgendjemand. Man hat ihn halt angerufen, aber aus der Villa heraus.
Das ist also nicht schlecht, wenn es nicht nur 190 wäre.
Ja, und für die richtig Verdienten gab es dann irgendwie noch die besondere Funktion, da gab man eine Telefonnummer an und dann rief das System den aber getrennt an und hat ihn einfach kostenlos in die Villa mit reingenommen. Cool, so nach dem Motto, hallo hier ist die Villa, wie wenn du Geld sparen willst, gibt da eine Nummer ein hier und ab geht er, Peter. Also es ist halt irgendwie, die Leute haben das halt auch mit angetrieben, weil die werden einfach Teil des Systems und genauso ist das auch bei diesen MUDs, wo die dann auch mit eingreifen, wo man natürlich da noch sehr viel mehr eingreifen kann. Wie läuft das bei diesem MUD-System, Andreas?
Das ist, ähm, bei mir, das gab da mehrere Ausprägungen von, aber das bekannteste ist das Lambda MUD. Lambda MUD ist einmal der Name des Original MUDs, in dem das entwickelt wurde und auch der Name des Programms, das man da verwendet. Und das Lambda MUD ist bei Park Xerox entstanden, wo auch Smalltalk entwickelt wurde. Und das ganze System fühlt sich auch so ähnlich an wie ein Smalltalk-System. Das heißt, es gibt kein Programmcode, der irgendwo auf Platte liegt, sondern der Programmcode ist in der Datenbank drin, in der auch die ganzen anderen Spieleobjekte drin liegen und man bewegt sich im Prinzip in dieser Datenbank. Das heißt, jede Änderung, die man an der Welt macht, tritt sofort in Kraft. Und man kann auch an den Objekten nachträglich noch rumwassen. Das ganze System ist objektorientiert. Man kann die Vererbungsstrukturen verändern, kann Methoden hinzufügen, kann da Variablen hinzufügen. Alles Sachen, die in der normalen Programmiersprache nicht so ohne weiteres gehen. Und dadurch wird das System sehr sehr lebendig. Also man benutzt dasselbe Interface, um das System zu besuchen, als auch um es zu programmieren. Die Intention ist da auch schon ein Stück weit, dass die Spielerfahrung nicht aufhört, damit dass man sich das anguckt, sondern dass das Weiterprogrammieren des Systems Bestandteil der Erfahrung ist. Also genau diese Trennung, die da bemängelt wurde, man ist dann plötzlich wizard und darf nicht mehr mitspielen, genau die wird dann nicht gemacht, sondern man ist genau aufgefordert, auch selbst mit einem System zu bauen, Räume zu erschaffen und Gegenstände zu erschaffen und auch Gegenstände zu programmieren, komplexere Systeme zu programmieren, so wie Weltraum Simulationen und so weiter und so fort. Das System an sich zum Leben zu erweglößen. Das war's für heute.
Ach wie lästig diese Pausen immer. Was konnte man in den Tosh Computer machen, Andreas?
Na man konnte da Linux drauf installieren.
Da muss man sich eigentlich keinen Mac mehr kaufen, oder?
Naja doch, weil man zumindest eine definierte Hardware hat. Im Gegensatz zu so einem PC, der aus Propel-Komponenten zusammengesteckt ist, ist so ein Macintosh halt guter, wohl definierter, solider Hardware.
Wieder was gelernt, aber eigentlich wollten wir ja über MUDs mal reden.
Da könnte vielleicht noch mal der ein oder andere MUDder sich hier mitgeben.
Dieses Lambda-Moo, was von Park Xerox kommt. Xerox ist ja die Firma, die dafür bekannt ist, fast alles erfunden zu haben, aber irgendwie aus diesen Erfindungen niemals so richtig Nutzen schlagen können. Nebenbei haben sie solche Sachen erfunden wie Netzwerke, Ethernet, Desktop-Publishing, Mäuse, Gois, Fenster, also eigentlich alles womit man heute arbeitet, ist irgendwie bei diesem Xerox Park rausgekommen. Und daran haben auch die Programmiersprache Smalltalk, die halt irgendwie da sehr seelenverwandt ist in diesem MUD, wo man eben alles zur Laufzeit machen kann. Die Villa ist übrigens auch in Smalltalk programmiert. Also ein Teil davon ist in Smalltalk, der das irgendwie sozusagen logisch managt, die ganzen Zusammenhänge macht. Dafür eignet sich eine dynamische Programmiersprache einfach sehr viel besser als sowas wie C oder C++, wo man einfach nicht zur Laufzeit so viel ändern kann, wie man eigentlich möchte. Man möchte ja eigentlich auch selbst... Während das Programm läuft, muss es die Möglichkeit haben, programmiert zu werden. Wenn es eben von den Anwendern ist, von denen, von denen wir am Markt teilnehmen.
Das hat halt auch den großen Vorteil, wenn da zum Beispiel gerade ein paar tausend Leute online sind, was bei LAMPTAMU durchaus schon mal vorkommt, also dem LAMPTAMU, dann möchte man ja nicht die ganzen Leute rausschmeißen, nur weil man mal eben eine Kurzzeile geändert hat, die man neu kompilieren will, sondern man möchte das dynamisch dazu laden können. Und das Dynamischste denkbare ist halt, dass der gesamte Source Code direkt in der Welt mit drinsteckt.
Was mich auch mal interessieren wird, ist, ist da eigentlich schon mal jemand drauf gekommen, MUDs irgendwie grafisch zu machen, also dass du dich tatsächlich dann wie mit so einer Lara Croft Puppe oder so einem Scheißdreck da durchbewegst und durchnavigierst und es trotzdem irgendwie noch im Ansatz diese Anmutung von MUDen hat. Also was dann ja eigentlich irgendwie so ein Grafik Adventure mit Chat wäre.
Die Idee ist natürlich naheliegend und das große Problem dabei ist, dass es sehr sehr aufwendig ist, die ganzen Grafiken zu machen. Also schon irgendwie Texte zu machen ist sehr aufwendig, obwohl man das einfach hintippt und dann ist gut und wenn man das alles malen muss, das ist zu viel für einen Hobbybetrieb und es gibt einige kommerzielle Projekte. Ultima Online ist sicherlich das bekannteste, da kann man sich halt eine Ultima Online CD holen, da hat sich eine Firma hingesetzt und hat viele viele viele Grafiken gemalt und wenn man die normalen Ultima Spiele kennt, weiß man auch wie das aussieht, das heißt man hat so eine 2D Sicht von oben und kann mit kleinen Männchen rumlaufen, nur dass man halt nicht der einzige ist, sondern dass da viele tausend andere Leute auch noch sind. Aber das kostet halt Geld, im Unterschied zu den meisten MUDs, die umsonst sind.
Wie viele Leute sind beim LAMDAMU online gleichzeitig?
Da sind schon mal über 1000 drin angewiesen, oder?
Die spielen alle in der gleichen Welt? Wie viele Orte hat diese Welt?
Ich hab jetzt echt keine Zahl im Kopf, aber so fünf bis sechsstellige Anzahl von Räumen ist für ein großes MUD durchaus nicht unüblich.
Sechsstellig?
Oder braucht man dann schon mal ein Leben, um durchzukommen? Hier, Telefon hier. Hi, hier ist das Chaosradio. Hallo Marius.
Ja, hört ihr mich noch, oder?
Ja, wir hören dich. Ja, ich verstehe, dass du was sagst.
Ja, ich mudde auch ein bisschen, aber ich hatte vorhin irgendwas anklingen hören, dass man bei irgendeinem von euch selber programmieren kann auch sofort.
Ja, ich habe das mal testweise aufgesetzt für die Sendung. Die Adresse ist gentlemanloser.andreas.org.
Findest du auch auf der Chaosradio ccde Webseite.
Ich habe da einfach mal, also wenn man sich da einen Account anlegt, kann man direkt anfangen zu premieren. Tutorials gibt es online auf zum Beispiel lambda.mu.mudd.org. Und kann man sich das mal angucken.
Wo mattest du normalerweise?
Ja, Gödenland, also ist die online Version von schwarzes Auge. Und ich bin da eigentlich eher über Zufall rüber drangekommen. Also ich habe in irgendeinem Buch mal einen Link über mad.de gefunden und habe mich dann halt in mad.de weitergeklickt. Und da ich halt schon seit längerem schwarzes Auge spiele, habe ich mich da halt einfach reingeklebt und war halt spannend von Anfang an.
Wie lange spielst du schon schwarzes Auge?
Schwarz Auge jetzt vielleicht 5 Jahre.
Mit wie vielen Leuten zusammen?
Also ich spiele erst seit Kurzem jetzt hier in Berlin mit ein paar Leuten zusammen. Also vorher war es dann halt immer in den Ferien mit dem Cousin. Also Rollenspiel mäßig war dann nicht so viel, aber es waren dann halt immer die Abenteuer, die interessant waren.
Und wie häufig machst du das schwarzes Auge?
Ja, im Moment halt mehr oder weniger einmal pro Woche. Also wenn alle Zeit haben.
Und Mats?
Ja, Mats je nachdem. Also ich bin halt im Internetcafé, im Netty, in Schöneberg. Und also da habe ich halt nur maximal 5 Stunden Online-Zeit und das beschränkt sich halt normalerweise da drauf.
Und gehst du da eher in die Mats, um da Aufgaben zu lösen und Punkte zu machen? Oder schon auch, um andere Leute zu treffen?
Man hat halt irgendwie so ein, also es ist halt ein Gemisch. Weil in den Chats hat man halt auch viele Leute, die einen irgendwie gar nicht interessieren. Und mit denen man, also die irgendeine Scheiße labern und mit den Leuten da hat man halt irgendwie einen kleineren Kreis. Und das ist irgendwie persönlicher, weil man trifft die Leute dann auch schneller wieder.
Also du benutzt das auch schon als Ersatz für Chaträume?
Nee, nicht wirklich als Ersatz, aber als Ergänzung.
Und du spielst die ganze Zeit einen Klaar im Gülteland oder mehrere?
Nee, man darf nur einen haben.
Echt?
Ja, also man kann sich zwar auch irgendwie kurzfristig noch mehr als einen zweiten zulegen oder so, aber ist halt so geregelt, dass man nur mit einem online sein soll.
Danke für deinen Anruf. Die zwei Charaktere, also die unterbinden das eine IP-Adresse. Zwei Charaktere, vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wodurch sie das jetzt unterbinden, aber was weiß ich, vielleicht gibt es nur einen Kugie, der gesetzt werden kann oder so ein Kram. So ein Quatsch. Ich meine, man hat natürlich auch das Bedürfnis, in mehreren Systemen zu sein. Aber dann ist das halt nur eins davon. Also nichts Neues, das haben wir ja schon gehört, das gibt es einfach seit es Internet gibt, gibt es irgendwie diese Kultur, diese Redekultur. Es fing halt schon an, wie wir es am Anfang erwähnt haben, ich schreib dir einfach was auf dem Bildschirm, wenn du auf dem gleichen Computer eingeloggt bist. Aber dann eben auch schnell einerseits diese Abenteuerspiele, also überhaupt erstmal das Konzept des Spiels, mit irgendwie, ich schlüpfe in eine andere Rolle. Der klassische Vertreter davon ist Nethack. Ursprünglich auch mal bekannt unter den Namen Rogue. Und dann Hack. Und dann, als es dann im Internet weiterentwickelt wurde, hieß es dann eben Nethack. Wo man irgendwie alleine als kleiner Klammeraffe auf einem 2D-Bildschirm, auf einem Terminal durch die Keller durchgeht und sich seinen Weg sucht. Wo aber auch eine hochgradige Interaktion stattfindet. Also erstmal ist das System unglaublich komplex. Wäre immer auf eine bestimmte Art gewesen. Aber vor allem ist es komplex und es ist sehr interaktiv. Auch wenn man es nur alleine spielt, ist es kein Multi User System. Aber wenn man das so spielt, also erstmal guckt man auf die Uhr, startet der Tag und dann stellt er fest, dass gerade Vollmund ist. Dann sagt er auch gleich Your Lucky Vollmund. Dann hat man halt mehr Glück im Spiel, als wenn es nicht Vollmund ist. Und wenn man eine E-Mail bekommt, während man das Spiel spielt, dann wird nicht so ein Text auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt, du hast eine Mail, willst du jetzt dein Ding machen. Man wird gar nicht aus seiner Welt rausgedrückt, sondern kommt dann halt ein Boote vorbei, der einem sagt, hier ist ein Mail-Demon. Ein Mail-Demon, genau. Der halt, hier ist a scroll of mail for you. Das ist halt einfach Teil der Interrogmented Reality.
Aber was war denn vorher? Was hat man kommuniziert oder wo hat man oder wie hat man kommuniziert, bevor es das gab? Das finde ich immer das Verblüffende.
Obwohl es jetzt elektronische Medien gab?
CBfunk zum Beispiel.
Aber doch nicht so extrem. Ich habe nie so extrem und exzessiv CBfunk betrieben wie Chatten zum Beispiel.
Du nicht, aber da gibt es durchaus Leute.
Ja, mag sein. Vielleicht haben wir ja einen davon hier dran, warte mal. Chaosradio. Ja, hast du auch was beizutragen zu unserem Thema? Versuchen wir mal mit dem, der ist ja ans Teil hier. Chaosradio.
Ich hab mal eine Frage, wo ich vorhin gerufen hab, mit dem Haus, mit der Villa. Scheint ziemlich zeitintensiv zu sein. Sollen sich da auskennen und so. Gibt's jetzt vielleicht auch eine 0800 oder 030 Nummer oder so?
Ne, meines Wissens gibt's nur die 090 Nummer. Und irgendwie, wenn halt, wie es so schön heißt, Happy Hour ist, wie jetzt zum Beispiel, gerade dann kann man eben auch über diese Hamburger Lokalnummer anrufen. Aber von Berlin aus gibt's, meines Wissens, jetzt keine andere Nummer mit Vorbehalt. Du kannst einfach mal irgendwie bei www.dievilla.de gucken und da steht irgendwie wohl alles zu dem Thema.
Okay, und dann noch zu den MUDs. Wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Das ist jetzt so textbasiert und mit den ganzen Räumen. Also wenn da jeder seine eigenen Räume machen kann, dann wird es doch irgendwann doch sicherlich ziemlich unübermiss.
Na ja, es ist dann im Prinzip wie in der wirklichen Welt. Es gibt halt beliebte Treffpunkte und es gibt eher abgelegene Gegenden.
Und gibt es auch so komplette Lagerpläne von allen Räumen oder eher nicht?
Die gibt es in der Regel nicht. Das muss man sich schon selber machen. Muss man mal alle Wege ablaufen. Ich meine, man möchte sich das ja auch angucken. Gelegentlich findet man dann Übersichtskarten, die so das Größte erklären, aber in der Regel gibt es keine vollständigen Karten.
Weiter geht's.
Hi, Count hier. Ich komm mittlerweile immer noch im GearGap tätig und so was halt.
Genau, ein Süchtiger.
Ein Süchtiger, naja. Mittlerweile nicht mehr ganz so süchtig, aber war schon ne ganze Zeit recht schlimm eigentlich.
Was ist das, was, also erstmal bringt dich ja irgendwas dazu zu MUDen, wie so ein Wahnsinniger. Was ist es, was dich davon wieder abbringt?
Man hat besser was zu tun. So RL-Kommunikation mit Leuten und ähnliches. Ich mein, die Faszination, die bei MUDen ausgeht, ist ja, dass man sich wirklich alles angucken kann. Und wenn man halt einen gewissen Level überschritten hat und sehr ist, dann sieht man halt noch ne Spur mehr. Und dann treten auch die Magier mehr in Kontakt mit einem. Und wenn man dann selber Magier ist, dann kann man halt alles mit anfangen. Also im wenigsten.
Und dann wird's langweilig?
Nö, nicht wirklich. Man kann halt einiges machen. Nur, man kann wirklich unglaubliche Sachen machen. Also ich hab da verschiedene Adventures von so Leuten wie Rochus im Morgengrauen gesehen, wo man dann mit drei Spielern sich in einem in einem großen Gebäude koordinieren muss, um dann ein Rätsel zu lösen, wo dann in jedem Erfahrungspunkt gut geschrieben werden und Ähnliches.
Klingt heftig irgendwie.
Ja, ich hab auch ein Teil des Kurzgeschehens gesehen und ich muss sagen, da stecken wir monatan Arbeit drin und das ist wirklich mit Liebe gemacht. Wenn man sich in einem Raum umschaut, dann kann man sich auch zu jedem großgeschriebenen Wort, also zu jedem Substantiv in dem Raum, kann man hingehen und sich da nochmal eine Beschreibung extra angucken. Also wenn da irgendwo ein Bild an der Wand hängt, dann kann man sich dieses Bild angucken und wenn auf diesem Bild ein Kopf abgebildet ist, dann kann man sich diesen Kopf angucken.
Na ja, es sollte eigentlich in jedem guten Mats so sein, dass alles detailreich beschrieben ist.
Ja, sollte es, ist es aber leider nicht. Das Morgensauen ist eigentlich mittlerweile sehr, sehr groß geworden. Also sie haben sogar angefangen, Magier wieder zu degradieren, weil die eigentlich nichts gemacht haben und nicht mit dem Dom herumstanden und hat keinen Kot gemietet haben. Und dann hat es trotzdem immer noch wächst.
Magier degradieren, ja.
Wie viel Zeit hast du so am Stück versenkt auf MUD und im Chat?
Wie viel Zeit hast du so versenkt auf MUD?
Im MUD hab ich irgendwie, Gott sei Dank, das ist mittlerweile acht Jahre her oder so, da hab ich dann irgendwie eine ganze halbe Jahre an der Schule dann halt einfach anstatt, dass ich morgens von Münster mit dem Zug nach dort in den Rechenzentrum aufgemacht hab, hab ich dann dort an der Uni unerlaubterweise als Nicht-Student von Terminal geklämt, ein bisschen Unis gelernt und morgens herumgehackt.
Moment mal, aber du bist nicht zur Schule gegangen?
Ich bin exakt nicht zur Schule gegangen, genau. Anderweilige Interessen.
Wie lange hast du fürs Abi gebraucht?
Ich hab kein Abi.
Ach so, wie auch ohne Schule.
Ja danke für deinen Anruf. Ich meine, also irgendwie so 2 Stunden im Café hocken und irgendwie dumm schwarzt halten, kann ich ja noch nachvollziehen.
Ich kenn das gut.
Ich meine, welche Bedeutung hat Abi?
Ja okay, stimmt.
Keine.
Ich hab das nicht gemacht.
Wenn, dann, wird's.
Wie immer am Anfang mit dem Wetter. Nachts nachlassender Wind, gelegentlich Regen bei 12 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wolkig, mit Aufweiterung bei 16 Grad. Und jetzt die Nildung mit Jörg Hoppenbiet.
Mai starken Sturm ist vor der dänischen Nordseeküste der Deutschschrift Achter Farus in Seenot geraten. Bis zum späten Abend konnte lediglich ein Mitglied der siebenköpfigen Besatzung mit einem Hubschrauber geborgen werden. Der vor der britischen Küste gestrandete Chemikalien-Tanker konnte inzwischen in Schlepp genommen werden. Eine Umweltkatastrophe scheint damit abgewendet zu sein. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat erneut Kompromissbereitschaft im Nahost-Konflikt gefordert. Der Jordanischen Hauptstadt Amman sagt, der Schröder, Israelis und Palästinenser müssten die Vereinbarungen von Shamil Sheik umsetzen und die Gewalt beenden. Schröder wird morgen in Israel und am Mittwoch im palästinensischen Autonomiegebiet erwartet. Eine Expertenkommission eingesetzt und nimmt am Sonnenabend ihre Arbeit auf. Trotz hunderter Hinweise gibt es bislang keine heiße Spur von Schmökel. Verkehr an neuen Berlin Richtung Leipzig zwischen Drei-Krotzheim und Beelitz-Halstetten behindert ein brennendes Fahrzeug weiter in den Verkehr. Bitte Vorsicht bei der Annäherung.
Moby Live in Berlin Mittwoch 22.
November in der Columbia Halle präsentiert von.
Das ist doch albern jetzt, also. Biologen-MUD. Wir erforschen den Körper so, es war einmal das Leben, gab es immer so eine Fernsehserie, eine Zeichentrick-Serie, ist das so was? Läufst du rum und darfst Blutplättchen suchen und wenn du ein Blutplättchen gefunden hast, kriegst du mehr Sauerstofffunkton?
Fast. Also, die haben irgendwann mal festgestellt, dass es halt ziemlich teuer ist. Die Biologen, so die biologische Community, die Wissenschaftsgemeinde, die Herren Professoren und Doktoranden an den Universitäten, die sich der Biologie widmen. Und weil ihnen das zu teuer war mit dem Rumreisen, haben sie beschlossen, dass man das doch ab sofort auch online machen könnte. Und kann man sagen, ja, nimm mal einen Chat. Das ist gut und schön, aber wenn man so ein MUD hat, hat man wesentlich mehr Möglichkeiten, so eine Konferenz zu veranstalten. Man kann dann also tatsächlich in ein Konferenzzentrum sich hinsetzen, mit mehreren Konferenzräumen, wo dann gleichzeitig zu unterschiedlichen Themen Konferenzen abgehalten werden.
Das kann ich aber auch mit mehreren Channels auf einem ERC-Server oder nicht?
Ja, aber du kannst dann auch so Sachen machen, wie das D-U-Time, man kann dann halt aufstehen und aufs Podium gehen und da was sagen und dann wieder runtergehen. Man kann mit einer Kamera das Geschehen aufzeichnen und hinterher wieder abspielen und so weiter und so fort. Also die fortgeschrittenen Aktionsmöglichkeiten, die man da hat, eignen sich wunderbar, um da halt mehr zu liefern, als es dir in einem Chat liefern kann. Oder zum Beispiel, dass man einen Client hat, der zum Beispiel Webseiten anzeigen kann und man einen Vortrag vorbereitet unter Folien macht, die auf eine Webseite liegt, dann den Leuten nacheinander diese Webseite zeigen kann in einem Fenster zum Beispiel. Und dadurch wird das halt wesentlich effektiver, diese Kommunikation da, als es in einem Chat möglich wäre. Und deshalb machen die das. Ähnliche Dinge tun, auch ausgegebenem Anlass in dem MUD der Sprache widmen, weil es geht da ja auch um Sprache und da eigentlich näher dran sind. Aber das mit den Biologen finde ich schon ziemlich erstaunlich, weil die ja eigentlich sonst nicht so viel damit zu tun haben.
Ja, man kann mit uns telefonieren über Chats und MUDs. Vielleicht ruft ihr auch mal einer an, der, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht tatsächlich gestalterisch wird und irgendwie Welten bastelt, ist für mich auch mal interessant. Oder eben auch immer jemand von euch, der uns erklären kann, warum er in welche Rolle schlüpft, also was ihm an seinem Dasein nicht gefällt und welches Dasein er dann im MUD oder im Chat eben annimmt oder sucht dort zu finden. Unter dieser Nummer hier könnt ihr auch die Frage beantworten.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Weiß ich nicht, also chattest du überhaupt noch, Andreas?
Ja, ich chatte schon gelegentlich. Provider hat halt seine Büroräume im Chat. Das heißt, wenn man von dem irgendwas will, muss man in den entsprechenden Kanal kommen und ihm sagen, hey, trag mal das und das in Nameserver ein oder du wolltest doch noch das und das konfigurieren, dann mach ich sofort zurück.
Ist das ein ganz normaler Provider?
Das ist natürlich kein ganz normaler Provider, das ist der Hausprovider sozusagen.
Das ist praktisch, warte mal, ich ruf deine Anrufe an. Was?
Bin ich jetzt drinnen?
Du bist jetzt drinnen.
Du bist drin. Also ich bin da Bade. Was? Bade. Ach so, Barde. Eins nochmal zum Anfang.
Singst du auch?
Ja.
Wirst du dann auch von den anderen an den Baum gefesselt, wenn du das tust?
Nochmal.
Wirst du dann auch an den Baum gefesselt, wenn du das tust?
Ach das geht, fessle Bade.
Nein, das nicht. Aber es kommt manchmal vor, dass man unangenehm auffällt, wenn man das zu oft macht, das stimmt. Das faszinierende daran ist, dass man sein Instrument bekommt, in der man sich selber aufsteigen kann. Vom Gesellen über den Lehrling, über den Sangesmeister bis zum Instrumentenmeister. Und dann halt bestehende Lieder findet, die man auf sein Instrument anstimmen kann und dann halt bestimmte Wirkungen haben.
Auf die anderen Leute?
Unter anderem. Oder auf ein Säbel.
Also zum Beispiel ist es förderlich beim Bezirzen anderer...
Du sprichst das Liebeslied an, richtig?
Ja, so können wir das auch nehmen.
Womit du jemanden zwingen kannst, dir zu folgen. Egal wohin du gehst. Solange du nicht in einen Kampf verwiegelt wirst oder sowas.
Warum gerade Bade? Warum willst du gerade Bade sein? Da gibt es auch noch andere Lieder.
Ich werde auch noch in eine andere gehen. Metamorphid z.B. interessiert mich sehr doll.
Was?
Metamorphid z.B. interessiert mich sehr doll. Da werde ich auch noch mal hingehen. Aber Bade ist einfach... Ich spiele selber Instrument. Und ich habe damals die Unitopia, also die Einstiegsseite. Und als ich damals das erste Mal war, bin ich halt auf die Badengilde gegangen. Und da gefiel mir die Beschreibung sehr gut von dem Ganzen. Von der Gilde selber. Und deswegen bin ich das eigentlich geworden.
Wie viel Zeit verbringst du da so?
Das kommt drauf an. Ich bin mittlerweile Instrumentenmeister. Und mein Alter, also das Alter wird ja mitgezählt. Praktisch wie lange du online bist, ist jetzt neun Tage und ein bisschen. Also das sind 220 Stunden reine Onlinezeit, glaube ich.
Seit wann?
echt?
Es war nicht so viel, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Also ich finde das schon recht anständig.
Das sind nur drei Monate.
Ja eben, in sechs Monaten kriegt man das schon zusammen.
Es gibt auch Leute, die sind da ständig online. Ich weiß nicht, wie der das macht.
Ja, das ist schwierig.
Du hast keine Flatrate sozusagen.
Und wenn du die hättest?
Dann wär's wahrscheinlich noch extremer. Aber im Moment kostet das halt Geld. Und deswegen kann man nicht so extrem viel machen dabei. Das Interessante ist auch nochmal, vorhin wurde Gott angesprochen. Dass man als Gott beschränkt ist und nicht mehr mitspielen kann. Man kann auch einen Zweiti anschaffen. Wo ist das Problem?
Man kann bitte was?
Einen Zweiti anschaffen. Einen zweiten Spieler. Also praktisch, wenn ich Gott bin, darf ich mich ja nicht mehr einmischen. Selbe in die Belange der Spiele. Ich darf nur auf die Welt gestalten. Und als Zweiti, wenn ich mir halt einen zweiten Spieler anschaffe, dann kann ich ja ganz normal wieder als... Ich weiß nicht, als... Irgendwie wieder ganz von vorne anfangen. Als Magier, als Vampir, als irgendwas.
Fangen wir doch mal da an, wo alle anfangen wollen.
Pflichträtsel, ich weiß nicht, wie viele das jetzt sind. Also Rätsel ist nicht in diesem Sinne, dass man irgendwelche Rätsel lösen muss, sondern das sind wirklich Quests, also Aufgaben, die auch locker mal einen Tag dauern können. Und wenn man die gelöst hat und zufällig 100% Erfahrung hat, also diese Erfahrung wird bei den Rätseln geben, aber auch so, einfach durch die Onlinezeit und was man gerade macht. So genau, wie ich da auch nicht richtig mit 100% hatte und die Pflichträtsel gelöst hat, kann man in sich entscheiden, ob man Gott oder Engel wird. Als Engel kann man aktiv weiterspielen und als Vorteil natürlich fliegen. Und als Gott kann man halt nicht mehr weiterspielen, selber aktiv, sondern man baut halt die Welt weiter. Das ist faszinierend, glaube ich. Das ist gerade sehr irre irgendwie.
Ja, das ist das halt mit dem Cyberspace. Alles.
Das habt ihr ein bisschen untergraben. Beim MUD hast du ja nicht wie das normale Reden, du hast ja auch die MUD-Kanäle, also die Kure-Kanäle.
Das ist sicherlich spezifisch für das MUD.
Das ist ja gerade das Faszinierende. Ein Plus eingeben, dann das MUD, wo man halt hin will und dann über dieses MUD zu einem anderen MUD reden. Das geht durchaus. Kennt ihr das nicht?
Na ja, das unterstützen nicht alle, würde ich sagen.
Ich weiß es nicht auf alle unterstützen, aber es ist ganz interessant zu sehen, was gerade los ist und damit zu reden.
Ich denke, ich würde das auch mal unterläutern, dass es gerade in diesem 100% Rollenspiel-MUDs auf den Unterschied zwischen In-Character und Out-of-Character Bitte nochmal. Also In-Character und Out-of-Character, wird das beim Monitob ja auch unterschieden? Also IC und OOC Kommunikation?
Sagt mir jetzt nichts, nicht dass ich wüsste.
Also es gibt halt einige MUDs, wo man dann, wenn man mit Leuten kommuniziert, also schon in dem Setting kommuniziert. Also man ist dann einfach der Ritter, der mit dem Barben redet zum Beispiel.
Also entweder du spielst deine Rolle oder du bist halt du selbst.
Wenn du das meinst Brulle halt, da hört dich jeder redet.
Ich meine sozusagen inhaltlich, ob man die Rolle spielt oder ob man als Benutzer des Systems mit einem anderen Benutzer des Systems redet.
Man spielt die Rolle. Man spielt die Rolle. Man kann auch ein Tier sein, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Es gibt Systeme, wo sozusagen beide Kommunikationsformen erlaubt sind. Also beim Chat ist es ja so, da ist man eigentlich man selbst. Man kann zwar eine Rolle spielen, aber das normale ist, dass man man selbst ist. Dann gibt es MUDs, da wird das teilweise unterschieden. Das heißt, man zieht dann zusammen los und spielt in der Rolle und trifft sich dann abends keine Ahnung in der Schenke, was weiß ich, und redet einfach so miteinander, wie man das auch im Chat tun würde, nur dass man dann halt sowieso schon im MUD ist. Dann gibt es welche, wo man tatsächlich nur in Character, also in der Rolle redet.
Also das heißt, ich kann nicht sagen, ich geh jetzt mal aufs Klo, sondern ich muss das dann entsprechend formulieren für den Fall, dass ich ein Rarde bin, oder wie?
Ich geh jetzt mal hinter den Busch.
Genau.
Ich geh hinter den Busch.
Man möge meine Abwesenheit.
Wir danken für deinen Anruf. Was denn? Zum grüßen haben wir hier eine Sondersendung. Du hast ihn gekickt. Und jetzt mach ich mal einen Invite hier.
0331. Whatstam 70 97 1 1 0.
Du misst dich halt gerade wie so ein gefürchteter IRC, Moderator, Operator.
Hier ist jetzt noch nichts zu mich verarschen. Also Alt F4 hab ich hier.
Ist schon klar, wenn du aus dem Raum rausgehst, fällt die Moderatorentätigkeit an uns zurück.
Entschuldigung, wir reden über Chats und MUDs und hoffentlich auch mit euch. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Dann mal los.
Ja, ich bin nun gerade angemacht, ich verwundere mich, dass ich direkt durchkomme. Über Chats und MUDs, ich hab nur gerade zugehört.
Weiß ich nicht, hast du eine Frage oder wolltest du vielleicht einen interessanten Aspekt aus deinem Leben im MUDs oder so berichten?
Ich könnte höchstens erzählen, dass ich letztens wieder jemanden im Chat kennengelernt habe und auch Leute wiedergefunden habe.
Wie wiedergefunden?
Durch den Chat, die ich, sagen wir mal, ein kleines Buddelkastenkind noch kannte. Und die ich dann irgendwann durch Umzug und so weiter verloren habe. Und ich dann im Chat durch Verbindung oder Anbindung an verschiedenen Zufällen wiedergefunden habe. Ich war mal eine ganze Weile Giga, sag ich dir was?
Das ist jetzt auch so ein MBC.
Genau, genau. MBC. Und da war ich eine ganze Weile VIP. Und das heißt also, hatte die Rechte wie ihr auch gerade, Leute zu kicken. Aber nicht beim Grüßen.
Ja, so ein kleines System.
So hat jedes System seine eigenen Regeln.
Vielleicht wollt ihr auch sagen, ich grüße euch. Das wär auch noch...
Das ist ja auch schön.
Normalerweise, also ich war ein bisschen langsam jetzt, weil ich bin etwas müde. Normalerweise ist mein Finger zuckt schon beim Geh.
Die Geh ist auch noch... Auf jeden Fall war es dann so, dass ich da irgendjemanden gewarnt hatte, dass er doch etwas sehr frivole Bemerkungen im Chat abgelassen hat. Und er fragte mich dann nach meinem richtigen Namen. Und dann kamen wir so langsam ins Gespräch und irgendwann hab ich ihm dann auch gesagt, hab ich nur meinen Vornamen gesagt, Mario und er denn wie der? Nicht so wie der, es gibt viele. Und dann sagt er mir einen Nachnamen. Ich so, ja das könnte hinhauen. Und auf jeden Fall hat er sich dann herausgestellt, dass das eine Altbekanntschaft war aus Griechenland. Genau zu seinen sechs Jahren. Und ja, das war auch ein Deutscher, der durch seine Mutter dahin gezogen ist und die sind auch irgendwann nach Deutschland wieder zurückgekommen. Und den habe ich dann wieder getroffen. Er wohnt zwar nicht in Berlin, aber naja. Und den habe ich dann wieder getroffen durch Chats.
Was für ein Chat war das? War das dieser, aber nicht NDC Giga, oder?
Das ist schon verblüffend.
Sehr öffentlich.
Ja, na gut, man kann ja dann auch in so Private Launch gehen. Wenn du VIP bist, kannst du die Leute in dieser Woche einladen. Außerdem kann man ja auch Flüsse tanzen. Es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit einen Chat. Wusstest du das nicht? Jeden Chat ist das anders. Je nachdem welcher Chat und so weiter, gibt es immer wieder neue Chatfreak. Das war früher ganz extrem bei mir. Als ich einfach tierisch Sport gemacht hab, sich mit irgendwelchen Leuten auf der Welt zu unterhalten, in erster Linie, weil du sie nicht siehst, weil das vielleicht doppelt so interessant ist, oder der Frau oder was auch immer. Und vor allem, wie gesagt, was diese Person schätzt, wenn man sich an jemand anders ausgibt, gibt es auch ganz oft irgendwelche Leute, die sich dann als gut aussehende So und So ausgeben. Da muss man schon ziemlich aufpassen. Da kann man schon ziemlich ins Fettnäpfchen treten.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja.
Da ergeben sich dann irgendwelche zwei Leute als super Blondine aus, mit blauen Augen und so weiter. Dann wird man schon leicht skeptisch.
Na ja, du hast es wirklich geglaubt?
Bitte?
Hast du es wirklich geglaubt?
Sag mal so, ich hätte es glaubt.
In diesem Sinne einen schönen Abend.
Eine Frage noch.
Nein, du darfst niemanden grüßen.
Nein, ich will niemanden grüßen. Es geht darum, ihr hattet mal vor, ich weiß nicht, ist ja jetzt hier, ihr macht darauf Spielumlungen, ne?
Ja.
Genau, ihr hattet doch mal irgendwie einen Plan. Ich glaube, ich hab die letzten beiden Sendungen auch schon angerufen wegen dem Fritz Clan.
Ne, das sind also nicht wir, die das veranstalten, sondern das sind Kollegen. Da müsstest du dann irgendwie, also vielleicht versuchen, ich würde mal sagen, das ist der Kollege Malodki, der müsste in zwei oder drei Wochen wieder hier zu hören sein.
Tritt ihm mal auf die Füße. Ach komm.
Ne, der ist sein eigener Herr. Schick ihm ein Mail, NVM.
Hab ich ja.
Triff ihn im Chat so.
Ich hab ihm schon drei Stück geschrien, ich hab jetzt noch keine einzige Antwort bekommen.
Meistens. Schönen Abend noch. So, jetzt gucken wir mal, wer jedes letzte Wort haben will von unseren Hörern.
Hallo, hier ist das Chaos Radio.
Ja, ich will das.
Da brauchst du erstmal bessere Deckung für.
Ja, allerdings. Versuch's noch mal.
Lost in the wind.
So ist das mit der mobilen Kommunikation. Hätte er CB-Funk gehabt, wär er wahrscheinlich besser durchgekommen.
Das hätte aber grauenvoll geklingelt.
Könnte es ja mal ein Funkgerät hinstimmen.
Das ist richtig.
Gäbs eigentlich nicht die Möglichkeit, eine Mathe per CB irgendwie, also dann CB-artige Vernetzung zu machen?
Naja, die Protokollschichten sind ja austauschbar. Also man kann natürlich durchaus, wenn wir sagen mal, CB ist ja auch audiobasiert, wenn man so ein System wie die gut funktionieren würde, weil man da nicht die Möglichkeit hat, die Leitung einfach aufzulegen. Aber es gibt ja sowas Ähnliches tatsächlich bei den Amateur-Funkern, so Voice-Mailboxen, wo man dann was draufsprechen kann. Andere Leute können das abhören. Die TU hat sogar mal einen Satelliten gebaut, den sie um die Erde geschickt haben, mit so einer Voice-Mailbox drauf. Damit hat dann Reinhold Messner mit zu Hause kommuniziert. Kein Witz.
Wie der hat an den Satelliten gefunkt.
Genau, er hatte so einen 70-Zentimeter-Funk. Und wenn das Ding vorbeikam, hat er es rausgepackt und hat gesagt irgendwie, hallo, viele Grüße nach Hause. Und die Bodenstation hier in Berlin bestand im Wesentlichen aus einer 70-Zentimeter-Funk einer Satt-Schüssel und einem Laptop. Und damit haben sie das dann wieder eingefangen und weitergeleitet.
Und was ist mit dem Satelliten dann passiert, nachdem Reinhold Messner gesagt hat, hallo?
Na, irgendwann ist er ein Satelliten.
Wer hat das bezahlt, bitte?
Na, das war einer der billigsten Satelliten der Geschichte. Der hat, glaube ich, insgesamt 30.000 Mark gekostet, bestand im Wesentlichen aus IKEA-Teilen und gespendeten Solarzellen.
The battle with the gods was magnificent.
Also der Satellit war aus Ikea-Teilen und so. Den gibt es jetzt im Katalog bei Ikea auch. Das ist der Solar-Satellit Aerobics. Und warum haben die das gemacht? Also das war nur so eine dumme Frage von mir.
Naja, die machen da halt Luft- und Raumfahrt an der TU.
Echt, die machen da Luft?
Was macht man mit der Musik?
Na die ist, ist das meine Festplatte? Ich wollte sozusagen...
Ich wollte Franzett gefragt haben.
Tanzen wollte ich fragen.
Ja, wir drehen uns gleich ein bisschen.
Gibt es bevor wir dieses Studio verlassen, noch irgendwie was zu vermelden?
Ja, gibt es. Weil ja bald wieder Jahresende ist, wenn wir wieder den Kongress organisieren in Berlin. Der Chaos Communication Kongress ist am 27. 28. und 29. Dezember. Zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr sozusagen.
Zwischen den Jahren.
Zwischen den Jahren, genau. Mit festem Blick auf das kommende Jahr. Ja und da gibt es gar nicht so viel zu erzählen, außer dass die Informationen in den nächsten Tagen etwas umfangreicher auf unserer Webseite sprießen werden.
Da ist jetzt noch nicht sehr viel zu sehen.
Aber das soll sich bald ändern. Wenn euch das interessiert, könnt ihr euch irgendwie auch in unsere Announce-Medienliste eintragen. Das Chaos Update.
Und dann kommt das sozusagen alles frei Haus.
Das war's Chaos Radio 55. Wir haben versucht über Chats und Max zu reden. Tschüss Brandenburg, tschüss Berlin.
Und tschüss auch die anderen.
Das ist ja noch nicht funktioniert das jetzt wieder.
Ich hoffe schwer, dass es funktioniert. Ich hab zumindest das Gegenteiliges gehört.
Das interessanteste Thema, hab ich natürlich wieder vergessen.
Was denn?
Tiny Sex. Das sind halt Sex im MUDs und Sex im Chats.
Das klingt für mich nach einem Thema, wo man eine komplette Sendung machen kann.
Für mich nicht.